So, was Windows mit meinem Sound gemacht hat, scheint zu gehen.
Was jetzt die Fritzbox 7095 AX Exclusive Edition, fangen die jetzt bei der Fritzbox auch schon an, irgendwelche Sammler-Editionen oder Limited Edition oder was soll das?
Ja, ich war ja auch, du konntest in letzter Zeit wenig erwischen, ich war die letzten Monate kaum an, oh mein Kopfkissen, also, kann man das Kopfkissen nennen?
Die Kopfabklage, nee, wie heißt denn das?
Da ist so ein Kissen hinten.
Am Stuhl, der Kopf nicht so da, weit hinter, egal, das ist verrutscht, wie auch immer das heißt.
Nicht Kopfstütze, es ist keine Kopfstütze, an der Kopfstütze ist ein Kissen dran.
Dankeschön für den Sub, Pog, Massive IQ Boost für den Chat.
Jetzt müssen wir mal, bevor wir Amazon gucken, ganz wichtig, Arch by the way.
Du hast mich auf YouTube gefunden, na gut, da bist du nicht alleine, das haben die meisten Leute, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Wir haben natürlich auch ein paar exklusive Twitch.
Wir haben auch ein paar exklusive Twitch-Enjoyer, wie auch schon öfters, immer wenn ich das sage, kommen die Leute und sagen, nein, nein, Max, ich nur über Twitch.
Also wir haben auch ein paar exklusive Twitch-Enjoyer mittlerweile.
Zumal es gar nicht so einfach ist, von meinem YouTube auf Twitch zu kommen, weil ich heiße ja komplett anders.
Das finde ich aber witzig, weil ich habe schon ein halbes Jahr kein Video mehr gemacht.
Ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass da überhaupt irgendwas noch empfohlen wird.
Aber ich weiß, ich weiß, es wird echt Zeit.
Mal wieder auf YouTube.
Oder wie es der Carsten früher ausgesprochen hat, YouTube, YouTubee Videos zu machen.
Wusstest du, dass vor allem eine Workstation free for private use ist?
Nö.
Also, dass das nur free for private use ist, nee, das wusste ich nicht.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, ich habe ja vor allem eine Workstation gekauft.
Und das ist for every use.
Aber wir müssen mal kurz Arch-Updates machen hier.
By the way.
Und dann im Laufe des Streams weiter checken, ob es wieder neue Updates gibt.
Was hast du geguckt?
Du hast nicht, dann hast du nicht die 2042 Videos geguckt, dann hast du wirklich diese richtig alten Battlefield 3 und 4 Videos geguckt, oder?
Da wo ich, da wo ich teilweise noch auf der Xbox gespielt habe und so dermaßen schlecht, man.
Aber das war damals die hohe Gaming-Kunst.
Wenn du da, wenn du da eine gute KD hattest, war alles.
Das war doch...
Die ganzen Call of Duty-Leute, die haben nur auf KD geguckt.
Scheißegal, ob du revived hast, scheißegal, ob du sinnvolle Klassen gespielt hast, ob du die Map, das Objective, was auch immer gespielt hast.
Hauptsache, Hauptsache gute KD.
Ich hab, wir haben nie direkt kollaboriert.
Wir haben uns ein paar Gameplays geschickt, das ist aber alles.
Wir haben nie ein Video zusammen gemacht.
Ich hab mal ein Video auf Englisch aufgenommen, für die Leute, die da gucken.
Ewig her.
Wir sind alle in einem Boot.
Ich glaub, Dates gab's ja gar nicht.
Crack X-E-File.
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Pog.
Prime ist ein gutes Stichwort.
Steht ja sogar im Titel, Leute.
Wir gucken mal, ob es da irgendwas Gescheites gibt.
Ich hab schon was gekauft.
Eine Sache hab ich schon gekauft.
Und zwar einen Staubsauger.
Gucken wir mal, ob der heute noch drin ist.
Gibt's ja, also, das in der Form gibt's ja gar nicht mehr.
Let's Player.
Gibt so viele mittlerweile.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sich...
...die Let's Players, ob es eine Let's Player-Szene in dem Sinn überhaupt noch gibt.
Dafür gibt es einfach viel zu viele Let's Plays.
Ich würde sagen, es gibt eher so themenspezifische Bereiche.
So was weiß ich, GTA-Roleplay-Szene, Nintendo-Spiele-Szene, sowas in der Richtung.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass der Krieger einen Schlag...
Ja, ich hab sogar noch das Video offen.
Das wollte ich mir mit euch irgendwann mal angucken.
Das hab ich mitbekommen.
Das fand ich extrem...
Ich hab sogar kommentiert irgendwo unter dem Video.
Ja.
Krieger hatte live...
...einen Schlaganfall im Stream.
Guck mal, ich hab das sogar drunter kommentiert.
Warum?
Alter.
Warum hab ich 1.300 Likes?
Das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt hab, hatte ich 8.
Okay.
Naja.
Steht ja auch ganz oben, das Comment, man.
Das hat er dann...
Ja, genau.
Das hab ich auch noch gelesen.
Mach mal wieder ein paar Videos, ja?
Komm mal wieder Streams.
Max kommentiert.
Hat mich echt ein bisschen geschockt.
Ich mein, ich wusste natürlich, dass der Krieger sicherlich nicht der Leichteste ist oder der Dünnste.
Und dass er viel striebt und sich nicht viel bewegt, hab ich mir auch denken.
Aber dass das so krass ist, hätte ich nicht...
Also, dass das so harte Auswirkungen hat.
Ich mein, ich bin ja ähnlich drauf gewesen früher, ne?
Von nicht allzu langer Zeit.
Ich hab 24-7 vom Rechner gegammelt, Kellerkind-mäßig.
Und...
Ich war glücklicherweise...
Hatte ich nie so den krassen BMI.
Und ich hab nie geraucht oder solche...
Außer, dass ich ein bisschen zu dick war und mich wenig bewegt hab, hab ich eigentlich nix Ungesundes gemacht.
Also, ich hab weder massenweise Energydrinks oder Cola getrunken, noch hab ich irgendwie geraucht oder sonst was.
Ich hab mich einfach nur zu wenig bewegt.
Und das ist tatsächlich bei mir die letzten Jahre über deutlich besser geworden.
Seitdem ich gemerkt hab, dass einfach ein bisschen mal so ein Tag, ne Stunde...
Eine Stunde, eineinhalb Stunden am Tag ein bisschen normales Spazierengehen...
Also, so hat das bei mir angefangen, ja?
Als ich festgestellt hab, dass einfach mal so eineinhalb Stunden am Tag ganz normales Spazierengehen ein super Ausgleich zu zwölf Stunden plus am Rechner hocken ist,
hab ich das ja so die letzten Jahre über mehr gemacht.
Und jetzt, seit eineinhalb Jahren, also das ist ja dann immer mehr geworden.
Und jetzt seit eineinhalb Jahren bin ich ja tatsächlich richtig viel am Sport machen.
Ich geh fast jeden Tag rennen und ab und zu Fahrrad fahren.
Ich hab das schon...
He!
Ja, wen willst du dafür noch groß zusammenkriegen?
Wen gibt's denn dafür noch, den man dafür nehmen könnte?
Wilder Igel, moin!
Danke für den Sub, Gamepad, danke für den Sub.
Der Finde, ich glaub den gibt's...
Ich glaub, der macht...
Der hab ich auch schon vor dem ich ewig nix mehr gehört.
Ich glaub, den gibt's auch nicht mehr.
Das weiß ich nicht, was...
der Kaboom macht, von dem habe ich schon eine ganze
Weile nichts gehört, was aber auch daran liegt, dass ich
das letzte Mal, der hat vor
eineinhalb Jahren oder so das letzte Mal angerufen, da habe ich
es gesehen,
auf Abwesenheit
anrufe und
ich bin voll assi, nie gemeldet,
weil ich irgendwie immer verdrängt habe und dann gedacht habe,
was sagst du denn jetzt, kannst du nicht
immer dich nicht bei den Leuten melden und dann
irgendwie,
war ich mir selbst
zu blöd,
dabei mag ich die Leute,
aber ihr kennt mich, soziale Sachen
und so menschliche Interaktion ist nicht so
meins.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich
der Lost, der Lost vielleicht, wobei
ich glaube, der Lost hat da keinen Bock drauf,
den gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Ja, ich
habe tatsächlich schon was gekauft bei Amazon
und zwar einen Staubsauger,
so
einen ohne Tüte,
den man mal kurz, den man quasi
im Flur stehen lassen kann und
wenn es mal irgendwie irgendwelche Tiere
zum Einsaugen gibt, irgendwelche Insekten oder so
an der Wand oder so, dass man die schnell rausholt
und wegsaugt.
Oder für Kleinkram.
Für
große, also großflächig die Wohnung
saugen, da habe ich so einen ganz, den gibt es auch
nicht mehr, da habe ich so einen ganz ollen
ich glaube
Siemens ist das, so einen ganz ollen
Staubsauger, der in die Steckdose
kommt und der hat halt auch Power.
Kommt halt ein Beutel ab und zu mal rein
und gut ist, aber ganz ehrlich, ich
habe den, ich habe den, das gucken wir uns
heute auch noch an, ne.
Heute gibt es ja bestimmt wieder massig Staubsauger-Roboter
zu kaufen und sowas. Ich habe meinen
Staubsauger-Roboter schon lange in Rente geschickt.
Das war mir einfach nichts. Ja, das
sieht auf den ersten Blick nice
und angenehm aus. Das war aber auch noch
einer ohne
automatische Entleerstation.
Vielleicht wäre es damit anders gewesen.
Aber ich bin mir da dazu übergegangen, einfach
ab und zu mal, wenn es mir
hier zu dreckig wird, mit dem
ganz normalen Staubsauger, den man in die
Steckdose steckt, durch die Wohnung zu flitzen.
Oder besser gesagt, hier durch den ersten
Stock zu flitzen.
Das dauert
20 Minuten,
wenn ich schnell bin.
Das ist vielleicht nicht super ordentlich, aber das ist
auch, das ist einfach
effizienter,
als das laufende Staubsauger-Roboter losfährt.
Und auch weniger nervig.
ich weiß nicht, ich bin,
ihr wisst, ich bin ein Fan von Smart Home und Gadgets,
aber Staubsauger-Roboter, muss ich
tatsächlich sagen, habe ich mir mehr von
versprochen, als es im Endeffekt gebracht hat.
Ja.
So sieht es aus. Und hier, Updates durch.
Ja, nice.
Arch, by the way.
Gibt es hier irgendwas Neues?
Check for Updates. No.
Reboot. Gibt es jetzt aber.
Du hättest dir das vor...
Ja, es gibt immer die schlauen Leute, die wissen
vorher alles. Ja.
Ich habe keinen Dyson-Staubsauger gekauft,
weil die Dinger sind unglaublich teuer. Da bezahlst
800 Euro für einen gescheiten Staubsauger.
Ich habe mir irgendein Billigding jetzt bei, bei
den Primedays gekauft, für irgendwie
Kleinkram einsaugen.
Und ganz ehrlich, wenn ich die Wohnung
sauber machen will, stöpsel ich das Ding ein
und flitze damit durch und dann ist das in 20 Minuten
fertig. Keine Ahnung, mein Staubsauger
hat wahrscheinlich, hat wahrscheinlich
vor 100 Jahren
auch mal, keine Ahnung,
100 Euro gekostet oder so.
So ein ganz
altes Ding mit Stecker, aber das Ding hat
Power, kommt ein Beutel rein und gut ist.
Es ist easy
und schnell. Es funktioniert.
Funktioniert einfach, genau. Error.
New extension added.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ich will keine, ich will keine,
ich will keine
Adobe
PDF-Extensions. Geh mal weg.
Bäh.
Okay, neues Inkognito-
Fenster. Geh mal auf Amazon.
Ja, das habe ich gebraucht zum
Ausfüllen von, ähm,
der, von der Krankenversicherung.
Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen, was das
für ein
Papier ist.
Papierkrieg
gewesen ist.
Und anstatt, und ganz ehrlich,
anstatt, dass man dort
irgendwie
das Ganze digital zur Verfügung
stellt, dass man sich da online anmeldet
und das online ausfüllt. Nein, nein, das muss
noch in PDFs gemacht werden, die dann
ausgedruckt werden müssen, unterschrieben werden und wieder
gescannt, weil man keine digitale
Unterschriften akzeptiert und sowas. Ganz, ganz
weird, Champ. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Keiner muss sich irgendwie
gezwungen fühlen. Ich bin froh, dass ihr am Start
seid. Es freut mich.
Ich meine, ich habe natürlich auch nichts
dagegen, ne? So ist es natürlich nicht.
So.
Reboot durch.
Aber, wisst ihr was?
Wenn ihr euch dazwischen entscheiden müsst,
Twitch-Subs zu kaufen
oder keine Twitch-Subs
zu kaufen,
dann kauft lieber keine Twitch-Subs und spendet
das Geld ans Tierheim bei euch.
Da muss ich unbedingt ein Update-Video zu machen,
weil ich bin jetzt ja eineinhalb Jahre dabei.
Sarix, hi.
So, ich bin jetzt ja eineinhalb Jahre dabei.
Und ich kann es jetzt ein bisschen besser
einschätzen, wie das ist mit
Grundgehalt, Bonus,
mehrere Jahresgehälter,
irgendwie Bonus,
Inflationsangleich, Rufbereitschaft,
Bonus und whatever.
Deswegen, da müsste ich echt mal ein Update-Video,
ich müsste generell mal ein Update-Video dazu machen,
weil ich habe ja damals gesagt, als ich
angefangen habe, ich mache nach einem Jahr ein Update-Video,
wie es jetzt ist. Und jetzt ist das Ganze
eineinhalb Jahre her.
So, was mache ich eigentlich schon mit meiner
4M? Nichts. Wir können das eigentlich auch in der
4M machen. Warum machen wir das nicht einfach in der
4M? Amazon.de, wir machen das einfach
in der 4M.
Da ist das viel nicer.
Wo bist du dabei?
Wie jetzt?
Wann kommen denn die?
Ich sage ja nur, ich müsste mal ein Video machen.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass die auch wirklich kommen.
Ja, ja, ich habe letztes Jahr
im April
1.4.
habe ich neu angefangen.
Naja, was heißt neu?
Ja, ich habe den Arbeitgeber gewechselt.
Da habe ich neu angefangen. Der Job ist gar nicht so
unterschiedlich zum alten.
Und witzigerweise ist der neue
Arbeitgeber auch nur 800 Meter
Luftlinie, so ungefähr vom alten weg in
Frankfurt. Aber das
Gute ist, wenn ich euch das erzähle,
ist es egal, weil es sind
quasi die meisten der größeren
Banken, Versicherungen und Finanzdienstleister
in Frankfurt, die sind alle so im Umkreis,
nicht alle, aber viele, so im Umkreis
von 1-2 Kilometern.
Da hätte ich eigentlich richtig
Bock drauf gehabt, schon die letzten
1-2 Jahre.
Aber ich habe mich
immer nicht getraut, weil ich
immer an mir selbst gezweifelt habe, ob ich wirklich
im Vorfeld 24 Videos produziert
kriege. Weil wenn ich nicht 24 Videos
im Vorfeld habe, dann weiß
ich genau, dass ich zwischendrin
schlapp mache.
Vielleicht mache ich, Leute, Leute,
wisst ihr, vielleicht
mache ich einfach
bis Dezember gar keine Videos, sondern jeden Tag ein Video.
Da würden alle
sagen, das glaubt mir keiner, wenn ich das mache.
Das wird mir im Vorfeld keiner glauben.
Und dann BÄM, da ist es.
So, Leute, lasst uns mal hier schnell checken.
Wir haben schon 19.15 Uhr.
Alle Angebote.
Arbeitest du nicht bei der Finanzinformatik, oder?
Also ich arbeite nicht bei einem
Arbeitgeber, der sich Finanzinformatik
nennt. Ich arbeite in der
Finanzbranche, ja.
Das ist richtig, in Frankfurt.
Ich habe übrigens, was witzig ist,
gefunden letztens, und ich finde, das ist gar nicht so.
Ich habe übrigens, was witzig ist, gefunden letztens, und ich finde, das ist gar nicht so.
Gar nicht so verkehrt. Und zwar
Gehaltrechner
Bund
gab es da einmal.
Ne, ähm.
Irgendwie Durchschnitt,
Gehalt,
Gehaltsvergleich, genau.
Es gab einmal beim Arbeitsamt
was, der Entgeltatlas,
und dann gab es nochmal was.
Irgendwas, Statistik.
Irgendwie.
Ähm.
Ich finde das andere nicht mehr, ja, das da, genau.
So, und da konnte man zum Beispiel sagen, okay, ich habe mal gelernt, also ganz ehrlich, ich habe hier nach DevOps Zeugspiel gesucht, das kannst du vergessen, da findest du nichts, da kannst du nach Fachinformatik oder Systemintegration suchen, dass es besser geht.
Dann habe ich hier mal eingetippt, wählen Sie eine obere Kategorie hier, Finanz- und Versicherungsdienstleistungen, Finanzdienstleistungen, welchen Abschluss haben Sie, Ausbildung, wo liegt Ihr Arbeitsort Hessen, das zeigt ja alles an.
Wie alt sind Sie, 40, ja, man kann sich das kaum vorstellen, aber ich bin 40, streame auf Twitch, rede in Twitch Emotes und sage Kackel, anstatt zu lachen, aber ich bin 40, man kann sich das kaum vorstellen, ja, ich weiß.
Ich zweifle da selbst manchmal dran, haben Sie einen befristeten Vertrag, nein, wie viele Beschäftigte, das weiß ich gar nicht genau, ehrlich gesagt kein Plan, ach, weltweit bestimmt über 1000, wird nach Tarif bezahlt, da müsste ich sagen, ja, aber ich nicht, weil ich außertariflich bin, weil ich mehr verdiene als der Tarif, dann sagen wir mal nein.
Wie lange sind Sie beteiligt?
Ich bin bereits im Unternehmen, ähm, ein Jahr, so, bla bla bla bla, bestätigen und berechnen, so, Bruttomonatsverdienst, 4720 Euro, ich finde das witzig, wie weit das abweicht, öh, okay, das kann ich, so, haben die hier irgendwas in der Richtung, oh, ho, das Arbeitsamt, Leute, fucking shit, gibt es da auch was mit Linux?
Nee, natürlich, natürlich nicht, ne, gibt es was, Administrator oder sowas, ne, krass, krass, Alter, die sind ja, die sind ja sowas von Bleeding Edge beim Arbeitsamt, ich fass, ich fass es nicht, aber ich glaube, ich glaube, die haben dort tatsächlich zu wenig, machen wir auch mal Fachinformatiker, die, die haben zu wenig Verkleidung, okay, gucken wir mal, was haben wir hier, Tabelle, Männer, wobei ist eigentlich egal, Gesamtalter, Branche, Finanz, oh, da gibt es,
da gibt es nicht genug, okay, Gesamt, ähm, Essen, guck mal, Frankfurter Main steht sogar extra drin, guckt euch mal das hier an, die Älteren in Frankfurt, aber gut, wie viele Fallzahlen, okay, das ist halt nicht, ja, das, ganz ehrlich, das ist ziemlich, das ist ziemlich das, was ich auch verdiene im Monat,
aber, Flottwist,
Fragen, aber ich meine, man braucht ja noch Luft nach oben, also das, das ist, gut, das ist Deutschland vorbei, das ist, das, naja, also die zwei Sachen habe ich gefunden, das hier mit Frankfurter Main ist tatsächlich relativ akkurat, das hier ist relativ akkurat, ähm, das hier nicht, finde ich, ich finde aber gut, dass es solche Sachen zum Vergleichen gibt, ja, ups, nein, nein, nein, so, die sind richtig agile beim Arbeitsamt, ja,
Jetk, geht euch das auch so, dass jetzt meine, das ist jetzt, das ist tatsächlich meine Frage an alle, die 30 plus sind, Leute, also, meine Frage an alle, die 30 plus sind, wenn ihr nicht lange nachdenkt, sondern so spontan sagen müsstet, wie alt ihr seid,
würdet ihr dann tatsächlich sagen, also, ich meine jetzt nicht mit, wie schätzt ihr euch selber ein, sondern, sondern, wenn ihr spontan sagen müsst, äh, Max, wie alt bist du, so, was, was ihr von euch, was euch, was ihr so, was ihr so, ja,
wie euch selbst also von euch denkt ich würde sagen irgendwie 24 oder so ich bin ich bin im
kopf über 24 stehen geblieben und das war 27 oder so auch geistig glaube ich irgendwie da hat sie
nicht so viel getan wer kein agiles development durchgemacht im hirn also ich würde sagen keine
ahnung 26 oder so also ich gehe also immer mal davon abgesehen ja das stimmt ich meine ich fühle
mich nicht wie 25 so körperlich oder soja also ich merke schon dass ich älter als 25 bin mit
mir 20 bis 25 bist ja so bis da so absolut absolut peak da hast du das gefühl so nach dem motto idee
kann keiner was machen du bist du bist unverwundbar und best einfach nur alles weg und dir passieren
was so aber gut wenn du das mit 20 bis 25 nächsten nicht denkst wann dann ja mit 25 bist du absolut
peak in allen sachen die du jemals haben wirst wenn man sich da nicht geil fühlen wann dann aber
das habe ich nicht dass das habe ich nicht mehr also ich merke schon teilweise jetzt so aber ich
wenn ich nicht richtig geschlafen habe da kann ich mich gar nicht mehr konzentrieren so ein paar so
ein paar alter sachen habe ich schon mehr aber eins muss ich echt sagen übrigens meine gaben
uhr ist der meinung weil ich jetzt fünf wochen lang nicht nicht viel sport gemacht habe aber seit
zwei wochen bin ich wieder voll am start aber davor fünf wochen ich viel meine gaben uhr ist
der meinung dass mein fitness age ist von 37,5 42 gestiegen in fünf wochen in fünf wochen einfach
fünf jahre älter geworden man das ist wenn er so weitergeht der gewalt was wissen informatiker nicht
warum nicht warum ist nie das nicht also ich kann dir aus eigener erfahrung sagen ich habe vor
ja ungefähr so vor zwei jahren habe ich bewerbungen geschrieben und habe vor halbjahren einen neuen job
angefangen also damit hat damit hat es zumindest funktioniert ich muss aber auch ferner der
fairness halbe dazu sagen ich glaube nicht dass die bewerbung alleine ausschlaggebend war bei mir
war es ja so ich wusste gar nicht dass es diesen job gibt mich hat jemand angerufen den ich von
früher keine Max beim Rennen und performeds bei uns gibt es war sich habe
gesehen, der hat das auf YouTube gesehen, müsst ihr euch mal
vorstellen, der hat bei mir auf dem YouTube-Channel
geguckt, hat gesehen, Max, ich hab ein Video
gesehen, du suchst gerade einen Job,
oder du bist nicht so happy
in deinem Job, willst du nicht zu uns?
Ja, hast schon recht.
Wobei, ich würde nicht sagen, dass die Bewerbung,
die Bewerbung wollte ich euch übrigens auch mal zeigen, ne?
Fällt mir gerade so ein.
Eine Bewerbung wollte ich euch eigentlich mal zeigen.
Anonymisiert natürlich.
Und hat gesagt, Max, willst du nicht zu uns?
Dann hab ich gesagt, äh, ja, erzähl mal.
Dann hab ich ein bisschen mit dem telefoniert, hat gemeint, ja.
Ähm, nice,
ich geb das mal an meinen Chef weiter.
Dann hab ich zu ihm gemeint, weißt du was, ich schick dir einfach
gleich mal hier Lebenslauf-Bewerbung
und so kannst du deinem Chef gleich mitgeben.
Weil ich hatte die fertig, ich hatte mich ja
kurz vorher schon beworben, allerdings bei einem
anderen Job.
Und, dann war ich
gerade im Bauhaus, da hab
mir einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft, 2022.
Da hat mich der
Chef angerufen von ihm, oder mein,
mein, also mein
jetziger quasi Chef.
Damals noch nicht. Hat mich angerufen,
da war ich gerade im Bauhaus, hab meinen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft,
hat gesagt, hier, Max, willst du nicht nächste
Woche bei uns vorbeikommen?
Dass wir uns mal alle, allesamt
kennenlernen. Ja, ja, okay.
Wann, wie, wo?
Und dann ging das
relativ zackig, weil, das musste auch
schnell gehen.
Das musste auch schnell gehen, weil ich musste ja bis
31.12.2022
gekündigt haben.
Und das war schon,
weiß ich nicht, 13. Dezember
oder so, als der mich angerufen hat.
Oder 15. Dezember.
Also wir mussten das
hinkriegen, alles noch vor Weihnachten.
Und ich kann euch ehrlich sagen, das war so
ziemlich die unerholsamsten
Weihnachten,
so ziemlich 2022 Weihnachten.
Das war so der ziemlich unerholsamste
Weihnachtsurlaub. Ihr wisst ja, ich hab immer Dezember
komplett einen Monat frei. Ich mach das ganze Jahr
über keinen Urlaub, dafür bin ich im Dezember
weg. Ja, ich war doch
die letzten zwei Tage schon, die letzte
Woche schon zweimal da. Ja, ich bin wieder am Start. Aber schön,
dass du auch noch da bist.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Fuck.
Was hab ich grad gesagt?
Das ist der Ich-Bin-40-Plus-Moment.
So beiden Gehirn.
Ja, Weihnachten war unerholsam.
Genau. Ja, Weihnachten war ich
Dezember bin ich immer komplett
komplett
daheim. Und
Wo hab ich denn jetzt Amazon aufgebaut?
Und das war wirklich sehr unerholsam, weil
ich hab mich erst in Würzburg,
wo ich mich beworben, hab das gemacht.
Hatte da schon den Vertrag eigentlich
auf dem Tisch liegen. Dann in
Frankfurt nochmal beworben und den
endgültigen Vertrag, den hatte ich glaube
ich
entweder an Heiligabend
morgen, am 24. Morgens
in der Post
oder
nach Weihnachten
am ersten Tag nach
dem Weihnachtsfeiertag. Ich glaube aber, ich hatte
tatsächlich aber an Heiligabend den
Vertrag dann erst in der Post.
Also, da habe ich
schon ein bisschen, war ich schon
ein bisschen angespannt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, in der Zeit, bis das alles unter
trockenen Tüchern
oder Dach und Fach gewesen ist. Das
war wirklich, und ab da konnte ich
ich konnte mich quasi noch eine Woche entspannen, so
ab 24. bis 1.
von dem ganzen Dezember. Das war
tatsächlich bestes Weihnachtsgeschenk.
So einfach hast du dich geleakt. Du meinst,
weil ich zum Vorstellungsgespräch gegangen bin. Krasser
Leak, ja. Also ich hab
in meiner Bewerbung habe ich
tatsächlich nicht
also mein YouTube habe ich nicht angegeben.
Oder?
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Lebenslauf. Nee, nee.
Mein YouTube
habe ich nicht angegeben, aber ich habe
Ah, mein Twitch habe
ich auch nicht angegeben. Sehr schlau, Max. Sehr
gut. Sehr gut.
Ich hab
mein
GitHub-Account angegeben.
Also, was habe ich denn? Ich habe hier gerade meine
Werbung offen. Was habe ich denn
da reingeschrieben für
Dinger? Egal, ich zeige euch das
mal, aber nicht jetzt, weil da ist ein Foto drin
und da steht auch Arbeitgeber und so.
Ich muss das erst anonymisieren.
Jetzt machen wir Amazon.
Sonst wird das heute wieder nichts.
Sonst schwätze ich wieder zu lange. Ich bin nur 32 Minuten am Labern
und habe noch nicht das gemacht, was im Titel
steht. Ich war nicht nervös
wegen dem Arbeitsvertrag.
Ich war nervös, ob das dieses Jahr noch alles
was wird. Was ich bestellen
will. Also nicht dieses Jahr, ob das 2022
noch was wird. Damals
war ich nervös.
Weil ich habe drei Monate
Kündigungsfrist gehabt zum
zum Quartalsende.
Sonst hätte ich quasi erst wieder
1.6. oder so anfangen. 1.9.
Keine Ahnung. Ich kann nicht rechnen.
Was willst du bestellen? Weiß ich noch nicht. Ich habe
einen Staubsauger bestellt. Das einzige, was ich bisher bestellt
habe. Microsoft kann
mich mal. Microsoft
kann mich mal. Ist das nicht
genau das, was ich predicted habe?
Ist das nicht genau
das, was ich letztens im Stream predicted habe?
Wie das Microsoft machen wird?
Erst ist der Aufschrei groß.
Microsoft sagt, ach, betrifft euch doch eh nicht.
Außerdem ist es
standardmäßig deaktiviert. Und mit irgendeinem
Update kommt dann so nach dem Motto, ach
guck mal, jetzt hat das jeder. Und dann kommt,
ach, guck mal, jetzt ist es standardmäßig an. Aber ihr könnt's
doch deaktivieren. Das ist genau das, was
ich gesagt habe.
Es wird mir langsam
echt Zeit für das
Jahr.
Wer will diesen Scheiß eigentlich?
Mal ganz ehrlich, Microsoft. Wer will Recall
eigentlich? Jetzt mal für alle, die nicht wissen.
Chatgehand hoch, wer nicht weiß, was Recall
ist. Wahrscheinlich gibt's da genug.
Deswegen werde ich's jetzt einfach nochmal sagen.
Microsoft, also
Moment, ich trink erstmal was. Da könnt
ihr sagen, wer es nicht weiß. Oder machen wir's
mal anders. Machen wir's mal anders.
Twitch mag ja
Zuschauerinteraktion.
Macht man ein Plus, wer
weiß, was Recall ist, oder
ein Daumen hoch, oder was auch immer. Und ein Minus,
oder eine Eins, oder eine Null, oder
was auch immer, wenn ihr's
Minus, wenn ihr's nicht wisst.
Hier.
Chatinteraktion geht durch die Decke.
Direkt Boost
auf die, auf die, direkt
der Weg auf die Startseite.
Übrigens habe ich gelesen, es gibt
Untersuchungen dazu,
wenn die Leute sehen, dass einer mitmacht,
dann ist der Anreiz mitzumachen höher.
Ich glaube, das ist auch im Twitch Chat
so. Kennt ihr dies, wenn, jetzt,
wieder die Zeit anfängt, wenn überall
im Zug, oder am Bahnhof
so Leute rumstehen, die
ähm,
Ziehharmonika spielen, oder sowas.
Und da gibt es Untersuchungen
dazu. Zwei Sachen. Zwei Sachen habe ich
dazu gelesen. Das erste...
Quatsch. So was.
Zwei Sachen habe ich dazu gelesen.
Das erste ist,
wenn die Leute, die drum herum stehen,
sehen, dass einer Geld reinlegt,
ist der Anreiz, Geld reinzulegen,
deutlich höher.
Also wenn die schlau sind, lassen die
ab und zu mal Leute was reinlegen, die dazugehören.
Und das zweite ist,
das Geld, was dort vor dem liegt,
das darf nicht zu viel sein, aber auch
nicht zu wenig. Da stehen ja immer dann Dosen
rum, oder liegen da irgendwelche
Schalen rum, wo man Geld reinschmeißen darf.
Da müssen immer ein paar Euro schon drin liegen,
weil niemand möchte der Erste sein, der was reinschmeißt.
Aber es darf auch nicht so voll sein,
dass sie denken, ey, der Typ ist ja schon reich.
Also immer regelmäßig lehren.
Falls ihr,
falls ihr mal Musik am Bahnhof machen wollt.
Okay, also
Recall.
Wo ist es denn hier?
Recall ist ein Feature von Microsoft
für Windows. Ja, ja, machen wir jetzt
keine Hektik hier.
Recall ist ein Feature von Microsoft
für Windows, was eure komplette,
also
komplette Session aufzeichnet.
Alle paar Sekunden wird ein Screenshot gemacht.
Ich hab die Abstände
nicht genau im Kopf,
aber es wird euer Bildschirm
alle paar Sekunden fotografiert,
gescreenshottet.
Die Screenshots werden abgespeichert.
Lokal und vielleicht
auch in der Cloud, man weiß es nicht so genau.
Und da wird dann beispielsweise
Texterkennung
drauf gemacht und wird indiziert,
was auf dem Bildschirm so zu sehen ist.
Das heißt, ihr könnt dann beispielsweise
nachgucken,
so nach dem Motto, ah, ihr wisst
doch, ich hab doch mal
vor fünf Wochen
mit
einem Typ
vom Autohaus gechattet,
ähm, was war da nochmal?
Und da könnt ihr Recall durchsuchen
und dann findet ihr das wahrscheinlich.
Ne, ich glaube
Audioaufnahmen nicht, aber da bin ich mir
nicht sicher. So, das ist Recall, also
das ist quasi eingebaute Spyware
von Microsoft.
Auf der einen Seite
klingt das natürlich cool, dass man sagt, ey,
du kannst quasi deine eigenen Sachen besser wiederfinden,
aber auf der anderen Seite birgt das natürlich
auch ein sehr großes Überwachungspotential.
Und ganz ehrlich,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die meisten
Leute wollen, dass
regelmäßig ihre Aktivitäten auf dem
Desktop gescreenshottet werden.
Wer weiß, was die Leute da so
treiben?
Gatschi Bass.
Und, also ich will das nicht.
Der Datenschutzbeauftragte,
die werden das schon geschickt gemacht haben,
dass das den nicht interessiert. So, bisher
ist es so, dass das wohl nur mit
Co-Pilot plus
PCs funktioniert, aber da würde ich nicht drauf wetten,
dass das lange so ist.
Wäre es garantiert 100%
lokal, wäre es ganz cool? Ne, wäre
es auch nicht. Oder sagen wir mal
so, ja wäre es,
wenn es ein optionales
Programm wäre zum nachinstallieren. Nicht als
Standardbetriebssystem-Bestandteil,
womöglich noch defaultmäßig
aktiviert. Das zweite
ist, es ist nicht Open Source, du hast
keine Ahnung, was es macht. Microsoft kann dir
viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Die können dir viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte Microsoft noch nie Scheiße erzählt.
Generell wird, es wird ja
im Internet, in irgendwelchen Werbevideos
wird ja nie Scheiße erzählt.
Die waren auch 100%ig
vertrauenswürdig. Es gibt,
es gibt ein paar Zusatzsoftware
zum installieren.
Zusatz, also von so
paar Startups gibt es so Zusatzsoftware, da kannst du
beispielsweise dich komplett
überwachen lassen mit Audio,
Video, Screenshots und sowas.
Und das wird dann auch indiziert und
in der Cloud gespeichert. Aber das ist alles Zusatzsoftware.
Wer auch immer so verrückt ist, das
machen will, keine Ahnung.
Aber das ist Zusatzsoftware. Mein Problem
ist, dass es Bestandteil von Windows ist und wahrscheinlich
in Zukunft defaultmäßig auch aktiviert.
Das ist das Problem. Nicht, dass es das
gibt, habe ich damit überhaupt keine Schmerzen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Dass prinzipiell große
Technikunternehmen irgendwie
lügen könnten, das ist ausgeschlossen.
Es ist noch nie
passiert. Ausgeschlossen.
Warte mal.
Mein Vater ist am Telefon.
Okay. Chatke, wartet
mal kurz. Okay.
Ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich habe mal
hier ausgemacht. Ich wusste nicht, ob es muten alleine
reicht. Mein Vater ist
wieder am Start. Ihr wisst
ja, das ist der mit der 26-jährigen
Freundin. Freundin in Anführungszeichen.
Er ist
75,
75, 76
ist er jetzt. Nein, nein Chat,
das habt ihr falsch verstanden.
Der hat keine 26-jährige
Freundin. Der
hat, das ist so ein
Love-Scam aus
aus der Karibik.
Die schreibt
dem immer, wie geil er ist und
so und er überweist regelmäßig
Geld. Ich habe mir das auch schon
versucht, mehr vorauszureden, aber
der ist da überzeugt von,
dass die ihn geil finden.
Aber er soll mit seinem Geld machen, was er
will. Mehr als sagen kann ich es
nicht. Ich habe ja eigentlich gehofft,
dass er endlich
mal ins Pflegeheim jetzt geht.
Der war
ja, er war ja sogar schon im Pflegeheim.
Aber er ist da wieder abgehauen.
Hab ich gerade erfahren.
Weil der kommt halt alleine nicht, klar.
Und er wohnt auch zu weit weg. Außerdem will ich mich nicht,
will ich den nicht pflegen müssen
oder sowas. Mein Vater ist kein
cooler Typ. Ich habe mit meinem Vater
30 Jahre
fast nichts zu tun.
Ich habe mit meinem Vater nur immer dann was
zu tun, wenn er Geld gebraucht hat
oder jetzt, wo es ihm nicht mehr so gut
geht. Nicht, dass ich mit meinem
Vater irgendwie sonderlich dicke wäre.
Aber...
Ja.
Und im Prinzip...
Genau. Im Prinzip hat er gerade angerufen
und hat gesagt, ich bin wieder im Land.
Ich habe gesagt, Moment, du bist wieder im Land?
Ich dachte, du bist jetzt im Pflegeheim.
Und dann meinte er, ne, das
kannst du doch keinem zumuten. Er war
irgendwie im Ausland. Vielleicht war er in der Karibik oder so.
Keine Ahnung. Aber ich weiß nicht.
Der blickt aber auch nicht mehr durch.
Wer weiß, was der
sich da zusammen fantasiert.
Keine Ahnung. Und dann habe ich gesagt,
ich denke, du warst im Pflegeheim. Er hat gesagt, das kann es doch keiner
gemeint. Das kannst du doch keinem zumuten. Es kommt jetzt
irgendwie so ein mobiler Pflegedienst.
Ich habe nur Glück, dass er viel Rente bekommt.
Sonst wäre er laufen am starten
und wollte Geld haben. Da habe ich echt Glück,
dass er so viel Rente kriegt.
Also er kriegt nicht Rente, weil er so viel Rente einbezahlt hat,
sondern weil er mit einer Beamtin verheiratet war.
Und
die ist gestorben, bevor sie sich scheiden
lassen konnte.
Da hat er echt Glück gehabt.
Jetzt bekommt er fast 2.000 Euro im Monat Rente
überwiesen. Und davon wird er wahrscheinlich
Der kommt trotzdem übrigens nicht klar damit.
Also dem reicht das immer noch nicht.
Aber da muss er seine ganzen
Love Scams
bezahlen. Da gibt es keinen Kapper.
Das ist so. Außerdem,
das habe ich ja schon mal erzählt,
außerdem ist mein Vater ein alter Scammer.
Was witzig ist, weil jetzt lässt er
sich scammen. Früher hat er die Leute gescampt.
Wusstet ihr, dass sogar damals die
Bild-Zeitung darüber berichtet hat?
Also damals, das war, keine Ahnung,
1990 oder irgendwann.
Keine Ahnung. Da hat die Bild-Zeitung
tatsächlich über das Scambusiness
von meinem Vater berichtet.
Ja.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Big Leak. Ja.
Es ist, weil die Bild auch so
wenig berichtet hat, ja.
Hat er denn nicht eine Agentur in Frankfurt?
Ja. Der hatte eine Partnervermittlung in Frankfurt.
Eine Vermittlung.
Eine Partnervermittlung.
Im Prinzip hat er ja keine Partner
vermittelt.
Also das Scambusiness
lief folgendermaßen.
Was übrigens witzig ist an der Sache,
die gleichen Sachen passieren ja
heute im Internet auch.
Diese ganze Scammasche hat sich ja die letzten 100
Jahre gefühlt nicht
geändert.
Ja, glücklicherweise
verdiene ich nicht mehr als 100k im Jahr.
Dank Teilzeit.
Ja, das ist so.
Wenn du über 100.000 Euro im Jahr brutto verdienst,
dann musst du für Pflegeheimkosten
und so mit aufkommen.
Wobei das glücklicherweise durch die Anzahl
der Kinder geteilt wird und hat noch ein paar andere.
Und bestimmt gibt es auch noch mehr,
von denen man nichts weiß.
Ja, also das Scambusiness war folgendes
von meinem Vater.
Der hatte eine Partnervermittlung in Frankfurt.
Also ich meine, ich war damals richtig klein.
Ja, ich war richtig klein.
Ist übrigens auch der Grund,
warum ich, wenn ich eine Sache wirklich
sehr ordentlich mache, ist, dann ist es
Steuer und Steuerberater
zusammen, weil
egal, kommen wir gleich zu.
Zumindest, der
hatte ein,
der hatte eine Partnervermittlung in Frankfurt
und
die Masche war halt folgendes.
Da sind
meistens dann irgendwelche älteren Damen
hingekommen, wo vielleicht auch der Mann schon gestorben
ist und haben gesagt, oh, sie suchen halt einen Partner.
Mein Vater hat denen irgendwie einen
überteuerten
Knebelvertrag, ich weiß
ja nicht, was da genau drinnen stand, aber so
hat sich das für mich
angehört, irgendwie mit
zwei Jahren Mindestvertragslaufzeit
oder irgendwie sowas, aufgeschwätzt
und dann, um
die bei der Stange zu halten, dass die regelmäßig
eben auch ihre Beiträge bezahlen und sich da keiner
aufregt, hatte der eine Gruppe
von älteren Herren,
die sind einfach immer zu denen heimgegangen
und haben denen schöne Augen gemacht.
Also das war quasi
Love-Scam, aber
die Oldschool-Love-Scam-Geschichte.
Der hatte so
drei, vier Kerle,
die sind dann zu den Omas heim
und haben den Omas schöne Augen gemacht. Der hat natürlich nie
irgendjemand vermittelt oder so.
Das war die Taktik.
Der hat die zu denen heimgeschickt
und die haben dann gesagt, oh, Frau
Müller, es ist ja so toll
hier und
ich mag ihren Hund und die waren halt super
super verliebt und happy und haben natürlich immer
schöne hunderte Monatsbeiträge bezahlt
und alles.
Der Trick war aber nie irgendjemand zu vermitteln.
Das war einfach nur, das war einfach
Scam im Endeffekt. Einfach war das richtig krasser Scam.
Und
letztendlich
wäre mir das
eigentlich egal gewesen, weil ich meine,
man kann immer noch sagen, okay, die haben die Verträge
freiwillig unterschrieben.
Den hat der dann auch mal
angezeigt.
Und es muss wohl im, während der Verhandlung
so wurde mir das
berichtet, ja, während der Verhandlung
müssen wohl auch die
Verträge, die er gemacht hat mit den Omas
zum, zum, zur
zur Sprache gekommen sein.
Und da muss wohl der Richter
eine Oma gefragt haben, Frau Müller,
wie konnten sie denn sowas
unterschreiben?
Also das muss wohl schon wirklich ein Hammer gewesen
sein, was sie da
unterschrieben haben. Naja,
zumindest, eigentlich wäre es mir
egal, ich war, es ist Scam, aber ich denke,
die Leute haben das in freien Stücken,
freien Stücken unterschrieben.
Aber, was mir nicht
egal ist und warum ich,
eines der Gründe, warum ich meinem Vater nicht so,
nicht so gut klar gekommen bin, ist,
dass er damals abgehauen ist. Da war ich
noch klein, da ist abgehauen,
ähm, und hat
keinen Unterhalt bezahlt. Obwohl
der damals mit seinem Scambusiness
richtig fett Kohle verdient
hat, aber richtig fett Kohle.
Hat die ganzen Omas gescampt.
Und hat keinen Unterhalt bezahlt.
Und die Aussage von
meinem Vater damals war,
er brauche erstmal 10.000 Mark
im Monat für sich, dann kann er Unterhalt bezahlen.
Das hat er eins zu eins
so gebracht.
Ich brauche erstmal 10k für mich im Monat,
dann können wir über Unterhalt reden.
Das ist natürlich schon nicht so nett.
Meiner Mutter gegenüber.
Davon will er heute übrigens
nichts mehr wissen. Wenn ich ihn darauf anspreche,
wenn ich ihn darauf anspreche,
dann sagt er, ah, komm endlich mit den alten Sachen,
du hast doch schon längst verjährt,
lass mich in Ruhe mit dem alten Zeug und sowas.
Der weiß aber genau, dass das stimmt.
Müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, ja,
ihr verpisst euch,
hinterlasst quasi eine Mutter mit
Kind, alleinerziehend,
und wenn ihr den Unterhalt haben
will, der ihr zusteht,
sagst du ihm,
ne, also bevor ich nicht 10.000
im Monat für mich habe, kann ich dir
keinen Unterhalt bezahlen.
Das musst du dir erstmal vorstellen.
So, und dann, wie das so ist,
wurde er angezeigt,
wegen seinem Scambusiness,
aber
nicht verurteilt,
wegen seinem Scambusiness.
Das war alles wasserdicht.
Wofür er aber fast in den Knast gekommen wäre,
wäre, wohlgemerkt,
das ist dann
noch halbwegs glimpflich ausgegangen,
weil er nicht ordentlich seine
Steuern bezahlt hat.
Ich sag euch eins, Leute.
Ihr könnt so viel scammen, wie ihr wollt.
Sobald ihr anfangt, das Finanzamt zu scammen,
habt ihr gelitten.
Und er dachte halt, er ist schlauer als alle,
aber das Finanzamt hat's
gemerkt.
Und da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
da war ich klein, also wie gesagt,
das ist alles schon ewig her, da war ich klein,
und
ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, dass ich wusste,
mein Vater war im Knast,
in Untersuchungshaft, muss man dazu sagen,
wegen Problemen mit
der Steuer und dem Finanzamt.
Und ich kann euch eins sagen,
wenn ihr klein seid und mit eurem Vater
im Gefängnis telefoniert, weil er
bei seiner Steuererklärung beschissen hat,
das hat einen gewissen Effekt
auf euch, dass ihr eure Steuererklärung immer
ordentlich macht.
Oder ihr fangt auch an, wie verrückt die Leute zu scammen.
Das könnt ihr euch vorstellen.
Also,
ich bin überkorrekt,
was Steuererklärung und sowas
angeht. Ja, so.
So viel zu meinem Vater. Und wie gesagt,
deswegen sind wir da nicht so,
hatten wir nicht so viel Kontakt
die letzten Jahre.
Ist halt, ist halt
assi.
Und übrigens, heute erzählt er mir,
dass das ja alles nicht stimmt. Also, der weiß das,
der weiß das, sagt immer, ich soll ihn mit dem alten Zeug
in Ruhe lassen, der weiß das.
Und letztens
ging es auch wieder darum, da ich ihm gesagt habe, Alter,
du kommst immer nur, wenn irgendwas ist.
Immer nur, wenn du irgendwas brauchst, wenn irgendwas nicht geht.
Und da hat er gemeint,
nee, nee, was ich ihm sagen würde, stimmt alles gar nicht.
Hat ja meine Mutter damals 30, äh,
dreimal 50.000 Mark überwiesen
und die hätte einfach nicht genug gekriegt.
Und so, was der sich für eine Scheiße.
Der denkt sich on the fly Ausreden aus.
Das kann der echt gut.
Stimmt nichts davon.
Naja, eigentlich wollten wir Amazon
einkaufen, ne, und nicht über meinen Vater reden.
Amazon wartet, genau.
Ah ja, das,
der wurde, wie gesagt,
mein Vater wurde nie verurteilt wegen seinem
Scambusiness.
Weil er das offiziell zu keinem Scam macht.
Wenn man es mal genau nimmt.
Ich finde schon, dass das Scam ist.
Zumindest aber mal
moralisch gesehen auf jeden Fall
Scam.
Rechtlich gesehen kein Scam.
X-Fail, danke für den Sub.
Also,
merkt euch,
ihr dürft Leute scammen, also das ist das, was man daraus lernen kann
aus der Geschichte mit meinem Vater.
Merkt euch, ihr dürft Leute scammen,
wenn ihr es rechtlich
wasserdicht macht.
Ihr solltet aber nie bei eurer Steuererklärung
bescheißen.
Meinst du, er hätte es gelernt? Nö.
Bestimmt nicht.
Der erzählt mir heute noch, wie blöd
die Leute waren, dass die da drauf reingefallen sind.
Was ich witzig finde, ne,
mein Vater hat damals mit quasi oldschool
Love Scam, wenn man es so will,
die Leute beschissen und heute
wird
er mit Love Scam
beschissen.
Eigentlich fast schon
lustig, nur mehr.
Aber er sieht es ja nicht so,
dass er beschissen wird.
Der glaubt ja, die finden ihn wirklich toll.
Ja, wisst ihr, weil auch eine 26
jährige aus der Karibik
einen 75 jährigen
Rentner aus Deutschland
ganz geil findet.
Wer kann sich das nicht vorstellen?
Es gibt ja nichts besseres als
75 jährige Rentner.
Nee.
Die wollen da nicht weg.
Die wollen die Kohle haben.
So, jetzt aber.
Stunde geschwätzt, bisschen sidetracked worden.
Mein Vater hat noch zwischendurch angerufen.
Ich wollte den ja eigentlich.
Eigentlich hatte ich vor, zu sagen,
hier Papa, benutzt du eigentlich noch deine
Linux-Kiste?
Und ich wollte ihn fragen,
sag doch den Leuten mal, es ist das Jahr
des Linux-Desktops. Eigentlich wollte ich, dass er das sagt.
Aber der hat wieder mit so viel
Zeug angefangen,
sobald ich das Mikrofon eingeschaltet hätte,
wäre ich Gefahr gelaufen,
dass der sonstige
wirre,
private Dinger erzählt,
die ihr nicht hören sollt, ja.
So, also Amazon.
Amazon.
Ich kenn Archilux-Installationen,
Speedruns, aber ich kenne
keinen, der das täglich und wiederholt macht.
Das ist doch eigentlich eher so ein Gag.
Okay, also, let's go.
Prime-Deals
enden in Kürze. Oh nein, Leute.
Wir haben's verpa...
Wir haben's fast verpasst.
Es geht aber, glaub ich, noch bis 24 Uhr.
Also, wir gucken jetzt erstmal Top 100,
was es da gibt.
Und danach gucken wir mal hier
die üblichen Verdächtigen aus.
Amazon-Marken,
SSDs, Smart Home
und Computerkrempel.
Da muss man aber schnell durchklicken,
weil wenn man sich das...
Prime-Deals, das ist...
Wenn man das langsam durchscrollt,
dann drehste, da drehste durch.
Da ist so viel Schrott.
Du musst halt, du musst da schnell drüber scrollen
und ab und zu mal was rauspicken.
Also, jede Menge Staubsaugerroboter.
Die Storys von Staubsaugerrobotern
und dass ich keinen mehr benutze,
habe ich euch jetzt ja gerade am Anfang des Streams schon erzählt.
Deswegen ist das nichts.
Was ist denn das? Ach, eine
Heißluftfritteuse, zu deutsch.
Das könnte ich tatsächlich gebrauchen.
Ich hab so ein Ding.
Das ist für, wenn man mal schnell rasieren muss,
weiß, das, das
werde ich wahrscheinlich tatsächlich bestellen nachher.
Weil so ein Packung Klingen
kann man da immer gebrauchen.
Du benutzt doch Hobel.
Ja, mache ich auch. Ich habe mich heute wieder rasiert
mit Hobel.
So ganz, ganz klassisch hier mit Seife
und ein, äh,
einpinseln und hobeln.
Ich finde das super, das Ding.
Wenn es schnell gehen muss, das ist,
das ist angenehmer, also diese komischen
Rasierer, wie man früher hatte, die elektrischen.
Echt, ich finde das Ding, ich finde das Ding
richtig nice.
Wenn, wenn man das mal schnell, wenn man mal schnell
rasieren muss morgens, ist das richtig, ist das einfach
pock. So, also das werde ich mir wahrscheinlich
schon mal bestellen. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Staubsaugerroboter, brauchen wir alles nicht.
Kaffeemaschinen brauchen
wir auch nicht. Zahnbürsten brauchen wir auch nicht. Was ist das?
Exclusive Edition.
Was ist daran
exclusive? Sie sieht schon mal nicht exclusive
aus.
Sie sieht aus wie eine ganz normale
0815 Fritzbox
mit, Leute, der
Klassiker schlechthin. Ein
TAE Stecker. Die heißen
doch so, oder? Der
Oldschool Klassiker schlechthin.
Ein TAE
Stecker. Wann endlich
Glasfaserflächen decken? Ja, das würde ich auch mal, würde mich
auch mal gerne interessieren. Ich habe übrigens gehört,
die Telekom würde angeblich wieder künstlich den
Glasfaserausbau bremsen.
Die Telekom macht bei mir fett Werbung mit
Plakaten überall gerade.
Letztens habe ich mal den QR-Code
gescannt, der da drauf steht
und geguckt bei den Adressen, wo das Plakat
hängt. Und was gibt's? Das höchste
ist irgendwie komisches Vectoring VDSL.
Wo man sich dann denkt,
warum macht ihr überhaupt Werbung und tut so, als wäre es
Glasfaser? Es ist keine Glasfaser.
Es ist einfach Oldschool
Shit, den es seit 15 Jahren gibt.
Telekom Spangen, Alter.
Bleib wieder
ragequittet. So, was
ist denn jetzt daran exclusive?
Amazon
Edition Amazon
Exclusive. Ach.
Okay. Inklusive einem
USB
Moment.
Das einzige exclusive ist, dass dabei
ein USB-Stick ist?
Exclusive. Das hört sich an,
das hört sich an, als ist das
irgendwie so eine Special Edition.
Diese Fritzbox hat Goldkontakte
oder sowas. Im Endeffekt ist das eine stinknormale
ganz
popelige normale Fritzbox,
wo Amazon einen USB-Stick dazu legt.
Die haben echt Dachschaden,
oder? Okay, hier gibt's neue.
Ein One-Blade brauche ich nicht.
Was ist das? Was ist das?
Das sieht ja futuristisch als Fuck aus.
Ach, Tierhaare für das
Sofa und sowas. Okay.
Brauche ich nicht.
Aber Leute,
irgendwann, demnächst, dieses Jahr,
mal gucken.
Ich werde mir wieder eine Katz holen.
Das ist einfach scheiße ohne Katz.
Sagt.
Gucke ich mich mal um hier.
Ja, beste. Gucke ich mich mal um in den Tierheim,
was da gerade
kein Herrchen findet.
Ich nehme ja
am liebsten tatsächlich welche, die schon
ein bisschen älter sind. Da weißt du erstens, was du kriegst.
Und
viele wollen die nicht.
Und gerade bei älteren Katzen, umso länger die im Tierheim sitzen,
umso schlechter ist es, weil
die sind ja schon alt.
Ja, letztes Jahr im
November, Dezember.
Hier unten, Chico.
Hier unten rechts.
Die hatte Nierenprobleme.
Die haben mich richtig sad gemacht.
Wer braucht denn sowas?
Brauchen wir auch nicht.
Du hattest lange Probleme eine zu bekommen.
Das stimmt, in der Regel sagt man auch,
Katzen sollten eigentlich immer mit jemand
zu zweit, also mit einer zweiten Katze
ähm
vermittelt werden.
Kommt aber auf die Katz an.
Also bei mir, bei meinen
war es so, die waren explizit
haben die gesagt, ey
die haben Probleme mit anderen Katzen.
Also bei meinen zwei. Eine habe ich ja vom Nachbar hier.
Der Nachbar ist ja gestorben und
die Katze hat im Hof rumgejammert,
dass es nichts zu fressen gibt.
Das war die erste Katz hier, die wir hier im Haus hatten.
2013 oder so war die hier.
Und
danach habe ich noch zwei aus dem Tierheim geholt.
Aber immer einzeln, ja.
Und das waren jetzt die zwei, da haben sie
explizit gesagt, die kommen mit anderen Katzen
nicht klar.
Was beide aber toll fanden ist, dass die bei mir raus durften.
Chico, also hier unten
die. Hier unten.
Chico war eine reine Wohnungskatze.
Das haben die auch gesagt, die kommt mit anderen Katzen nicht klar und das ist eine reine Wohnungskatze.
Aber ich habe ja
den
also wir haben so eine Terrasse vor der Haustür.
Dann vor der Terrasse
geht es runter in den Hof.
Vom Hof kannst du dann entweder auf die Straße oder in den Garten.
Und
die habe ich
katzensicher gemacht.
Da habe ich so ein
so ein Netz gekauft.
Mit so einem Seil, was man so spannen kann
zwischen den Gebäuden.
Ich habe das Netz lang gezogen.
Habe das dicht gemacht.
Und habe oben noch so
an die Wand noch so
zwei Netze geschraubt.
Das sie nicht abhauen können.
Wenn sie mal ihre fünf Minuten haben.
Und das fand Chico so toll.
Das sie raus durfte.
Die kannte das vorher nicht.
Die hat sich erst gar nicht getraut.
Chico war eine reine Wohnungskatze.
Sie hier.
Sie heißt Chico, aber ist eine Katze.
Weiß nicht wer das so benannt hat.
Ich habe es einfach nur übernommen.
Die fand das so toll.
Die hat sich erst nicht raus getraut.
Als erstes
musste man mit Chico vor die Tür.
Dann ist Chico vor die Haustür.
Also Tür aufmachen.
Und du musstest neben der stehen bleiben.
Die ist quasi
ein Zentimeter nach der Haustür gestoppt.
Hat sich hingesetzt.
Und hat sich das angeguckt.
Und man musste neben ihr stehen bleiben.
Dann hat sie sich das 10 Minuten angeguckt.
Und dann wollte sie wieder rein.
Und das hat sie bestimmt.
Boah.
Einen Monat oder so gemacht.
Bis sie sich raus getraut hat.
Mal die restliche Terrasse zu erkunden.
Die kannte das nicht.
Die wusste nicht das die Welt vor der Tür weiter geht.
Stellt euch mal vor.
Wenn ihr reine Wohnungskatze seid.
Und ihr werdet nur in einer Wohnung.
Oder in einer Wohnung gewesen euer ganzes Leben.
Ihr denkt die Welt endet an der Haustür.
Und die war echt.
Die war komplett.
Komplett verwirrt davon.
Bei uns auf der Terrasse.
Da ist es recht ruhig auch.
Da landen sogar manchmal.
Ich hab da so eine Wetterstation stehen.
Auf der Wetterstation landen manchmal Vögel und sowas.
Die letzte Katze die ich hatte vor Chico.
Die kannte das draußen.
Die war früher anscheinend auch schon mal draußen.
Als sie den ersten Vogel gesehen hat.
Ist sie ausgeflippt.
Die ist sofort weg.
Sie ist sofort in Jagdmodus gegangen.
So quasi auf den Bauch.
Und lang gerobbt Richtung Vogel.
Hab ich immer gedacht.
Okay du hast sowas schon mal irgendwann gesehen.
Obwohl die als reine Wohnungskatze am Start war.
Die war auch happy das die raus durfte dann.
Aber Chico hat den Vogel gesehen.
Und hat sich erstmal so erschreckt.
Scheiße da kommt was geflogen.
Es attackiert mich.
Ich muss jetzt gleich wieder rein.
Also für die war die Außenwelt echt nichts.
Aber nach einer Zeit hat die sich dran gewöhnt.
Dann fand ich das eigentlich auch ganz nice.
Und einmal.
Einmal ist Chico aus dem Fenster gesprungen.
Hab ich nicht hier noch irgendwie ein Bild von Chico?
Ja Chico.
Ach gut.
Chico schlecht ausgeschnitten okay.
Einmal ist Chico aus dem Fenster gesprungen.
Im Erdgeschoss.
Also nicht irgendwie von vorne.
Okay genau Leute.
Das wollte ich jetzt sehen.
Guck mal hier.
Was mir da empfohlen wurde.
ARD Sturm der Liebe.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja und einmal ist Chico im Erdgeschoss
aus dem Fenster gehüpft auf die Straße.
Aus dem Wohnzimmer Fenster auf die Straße.
Die war so schnell draußen.
Da konntste gar nicht gucken.
Und dann stand die.
Und dann stand die draußen.
Und in dem Moment wo die draußen war hat die festgestellt.
Oh Scheiße.
Draußen ist aber gefährlich.
Ich will lieber wieder rein.
Und dann.
Ist sie nicht wieder reingekommen.
Dann hat sie Panik geschoben da draußen.
Dann bin ich ganz schnell raus gerannt.
Und hab sie wieder geholt.
Da hab ich geschwitzt bei.
So aber jetzt gucken wir mal weiter bei Amazon.
Repeater brauchen wir nicht.
Heizungsthermostat brauchen wir auch nicht.
Yoga.
Ja das ist bestimmt sehr entspannend.
Ein Yoga Notebook.
Ein Fernseh von LG.
Leute gibt es eigentlich noch.
Fernsehgeräte.
Die einfach dumm sind.
Die quasi so eine Art Bildschirm sind.
Quasi einen 55 Zoll.
Fernseh.
Der nicht smart ist und nichts kann.
Und dafür billiger ist.
Sowas gibt es nicht mehr oder?
Warum ich frage ist.
Ich benutze seit Jahren ja schon.
Ein Android TV.
Also ein Shield TV.
Über das ich alles mache.
Mein Fernseh braucht keinerlei Smart Funktion.
Ich habe nicht einmal die Fernbedienung.
Von meinem Fernseh in der Hand gehabt.
Die letzten paar Jahre.
Auf die kompletten Smart Funktionen.
Von meinem Fernseh verzichten.
Alles Schrott hier.
Ein Schlummer Otter.
Let's go.
Da habe ich drauf gewartet.
Jawoll.
Oh guck mal der redet auch oder?
Oder was soll denn dieser Pfeil hier sagen?
Was sagt der Pfeil?
Hat irgendjemand einen Plan?
Spricht der?
Sagt der was?
Brummt der wie eine Katze?
Swiffer. Der atmet.
Das wird mir ja zu denken geben.
Der macht Herzgeräusche.
Atem.
Wirklich?
Aha.
Also der schläft quasi.
Ach deswegen ist das ein Schlummer Otter.
Das ist quasi zur Beruhigung.
Ach so.
Ah verstehe.
Ok das leuchtet ein.
Kinder denken dann es ist einer dabei.
Ja das macht Sinn.
Ich kann mir vorstellen dass das funktioniert.
So alles.
Ist das Rasierschaum?
Ganz ehrlich Rasierschaum aus dem aus der
Flasche ist es ja nicht.
Aus der Tube.
So Spray Rasierschaum ist der größte Shit überhaupt.
Geh mal weg.
Ich rühre mir meine Seife immer selbst.
Ok.
Also die Top 100.
Also Chat.
Wenn das die Top 100 waren.
Da will ich ja nicht wissen was sonst noch kommt.
Top Marten.
Kundenverfügung.
Und Segway.
Optigrill.
Brauche ich zwar nicht.
Aber warum möchte man sowas?
Was kann der Tolles?
Der hat RGB.
RGB Grill.
Habe ich keine Verwendung für.
Dann gucken wir doch mal schnell.
Eigentlich die Kategorie die mich am meisten interessiert.
Ob es irgendwas gibt.
Smarthome technisch.
Was?
Optigrill ist geil.
Was ist an dem Optigrill geiler als
an der Bratpfanne zum Beispiel?
Außer das du noch was hast was du sauber machen musst?
Also wichtig.
Warum ist intelligentes Zuhause
Die Dinger sind ja noch schweineteuer oder?
Naja.
Das Fleisch brutzeln geht viel schneller und braucht kein Öl.
Naja du brauchst in der Pfanne
auch nicht zwangsläufig Öl.
Wenn du damit fein bist.
Du kannst oben und unten gleichzeitig grillen.
Ok das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Vorteil. Ja.
Du musst nicht dabei stehen.
Ich muss das doch aufmachen wenn es fertig ist.
Weiß ich nicht.
Überzeugt mich nicht so.
Wichtig bei Smarthome Geräten für mich eindeutig.
Es muss Flashbar sein.
Oder aber Offline verwendbar.
Also diese Sachen hier.
Wenn ich schon diese Blinkkameras sehe.
Oder Ringkameras.
Never.
Niemals würde ich mir sowas in die Wohnung hängen.
Ich brauche kein Cloud Abo.
Damit ich Sachen bei mir lokal verwenden kann.
Was ist das?
Warum ist das intelligentes Zuhause?
Warum ist ein Fernseher ein intelligentes Zuhause?
Man kann es ja auch übertreiben.
Das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Der Grill schaltet beim vollenden ab.
Schaltet er nach Zeit ab?
Oder kann der Grill irgendwie erkennen ob das Fleisch
ordentlich gebraten ist?
Und wenn ja wie erkennt er das?
Irgendwie per
misst er irgendwie die Leitfähigkeit?
Ok so viele Fernseher
brauche ich eigentlich keine.
QuietComfort Ultra.
Ich habe einen der ersten QuietComfort Kopfhörer.
Die sind wirklich ganz gut.
Ansonsten habe ich ja Bose gerade
was die anderen Audiosachen angeht
immer für überteuertes Zeug gehalten.
Was ganz ok ist.
Aber die Dinger sind wirklich nice.
Zumindest die die ich habe.
Von dem Ultra keine Ahnung.
Ich musste bisher nur einmal die Polster tauschen.
Und die gab es relativ günstig zum Nachkaufen.
Es gibt Shady Buttons für 10 Euro.
Das müsste jetzt gleich noch kommen.
Kannst du mir einen Laptop für 400 Euro rausholen?
Ich habe keinen Plan nach was man da gucken muss.
Generell mit Hardware
kenne ich mich nur aus
zu dem Zeitpunkt wenn ich mir selbst was kaufen will.
Ansonsten keine Ahnung.
Ok.
Temperatursensor.
Aber da muss man doch wissen wie dick das ist.
Was drauf ist und was drauf ist.
Ich bin von der Grill Geschichte
noch nicht so überzeugt.
Ok es gibt jede Menge
Heißluftfritteuse.
Es gibt Shelly Plus 2 PM.
PM ist mit
da kannst du quasi Verbrauch messen
und sowas.
Jetzt mal das Heizthermostat.
Nope.
Moin Silvius Max. Pog.
Ja.
Ich bin da und du bist auch wieder da.
Wie ich sehe.
Poggers Modge.
Der Sibaro ist der Cute Mod.
Du bist der High IQ Mod.
Wo soll ich denn Sibaro?
Den habe ich ja noch länger nicht gesehen.
Lebt Chainlaw eigentlich noch?
Ich glaube.
Ich habe noch nie gesucht zum Spammen
nachdem ich einen Monat nicht online war.
Gibt keine komischen ASCII Koks mehr
die gespammt werden.
Im Chat.
Bräunenstelz ist real.
Dann ist erst mal Entwicklung vom Archiv eingestellt.
Bis auf weiteres.
Da ist bis jetzt nichts dabei.
Philips Hue ist aus meiner Sicht
ein äußerst teurer Spaß.
Wo man mit selbst gestrickten Sachen
teilweise weiter kommt
und besser und günstiger fährt.
Leider gibt es keine guten Smartphone Angebote.
Aber das habe ich noch nicht.
Ich kenne mich mit Smartphones auch nicht gut aus.
Ich gucke immer nur,
wenn ich was brauche.
Und ich muss sagen,
ich bin eh ziemlich Boomermäßig
was meine Smartphone Auswahl angeht.
Ich hatte die letzten Jahre immer nur iPhones
und hatte alle paar Jahre ein neues.
Weißt du, das ist sehr unspektakulär.
Nicht, dass ich noch nie Android Geräte
ausprobiert hätte.
Ich habe jede Menge Android Geräte.
Aber kein Android Smartphone
im Betrieb.
Ein komischer Einbau
und ein intelligentes Zuhause.
Zoom Meeting.
Ein echter Zoomer.
Zoom regt mich immer auf.
Die Amis stehen voll auf Zoom.
Wir hatten schon ein paar Calls
mit irgendwelchen US Firmen
und die haben dann irgendwelche Zoom Links geschickt.
Bei Zoom kriege ich echt immer Ausschläge,
wenn ich Zoom verwenden muss.
Aber davon abgesehen, Teams hat auch seine Probleme.
So ist das nicht.
Soundbar.
Fürs Wohnzimmer.
Weil der im Fernseher eingebaute Sound
ist schon ziemlich Schrott.
Wobei ich da mir halt wieder denke,
bestimmt wieder sehr viel
proprietärer Kram,
der nicht richtig funktioniert
und nach einem Jahr eingestellt wird.
Okay, smarter Kühlschrank?
Oder warum ist der unter
intelligentes Zuhause?
Hat der irgendwas Smart Home mäßiges?
Nö, hat der nicht.
Warum ist der unter intelligentes Zuhause?
Das ist ein ganz normaler
Oldschool Kühlschrank.
Das Ding sieht verdächtig aus.
Bloß ein bisschen dicker.
Der Türalarm,
also Smart Funktion,
es fuckt.
Das Ding sieht ein bisschen dicker aus
wie die Xiaomi
Thermostate.
Ich würde die Xiaomi Thermostate aber bevorzugen,
weil die kann man flashen
und mittlerweile sogar
Bluetooth Firmware.
Custom Firmware, Leute.
Für die Teile.
Und mittlerweile gibt es sie sogar
mit
Zigbee Firmware.
Was richtig nice ist.
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wollten wir übrigens auch mal im Stream machen,
fällt mir da gerade auf.
Ich habe nämlich noch ein paar
und auch welche, die neu genug sind,
die Zigbee haben sollten.
Übrigens, das ist eines der wenigen
Open Source Projekte auf Github,
wo ich tatsächlich mal was donated habe.
Hat AliExpress keinen
Prime Day.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
AliExpress macht mal viel Mist mit.
Vielleicht hat AliExpress heute auch Prime Day.
AliExpress sieht immer aus wie Prime Day
und sieht immer aus wie eine Scam-Seite.
Obwohl es keine Scam-Seite ist,
aber sie sieht immer aus wie eine Scam-Seite.
Ja, eines der wenigen Open Source Projekte,
wo ich tatsächlich mal was donated habe.
Und
in Form von
Geräten allerdings hier.
Ich hatte mir mal so ein 10er-Pack gekauft
und habe glaube ich drei Stück oder so.
Ja doch, drei Stück glaube ich.
Donated.
Zu weiteren Forschungszwecken.
Allerdings nicht ganz uneigennützig,
muss ich sagen, weil die Firma lief
auf meiner Geräteversion nicht so gut.
Da habe ich halt mal donated in der Hoffnung,
die finden raus, warum nicht.
Und haben sie auch rausgefunden.
Haben sie rausgefunden.
Und ich habe jetzt
mindestens vier Stück im Einsatz,
fünf Stück im Einsatz.
Und die halten richtig lange.
Da ist so eine kleine Batterie drinnen,
so eine ganz kleine Knopfzelle.
Was ist das? CR
2332 oder so.
Diese normalen kleinen Knopfzellen.
Damit halten die über zwei Jahre.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Krass, oder?
Mit der Original-Xiaomi-Firm,
wir halten die ein halbes Jahr.
So, das brauchen wir alles nett.
Brauchen wir alles nett.
Schneller scrollen hier.
Luftreiniger.
Der ganze Shit, der hier unter Smart Home steht,
der sollte nicht unter Smart Home stehen.
Da werden wir nämlich auch schneller durch.
Leute, das ist legit.
Das ist legit.
Die hässlichste
Tilt
und äh, also
dreh- und neigbare Kamera,
die ich je gesehen habe.
Das sieht so hässlich aus.
Außerdem ist es eine Plink und braucht irgendwie
Online-Subscription, damit ich mir lokales Zeug angucken kann.
Kommt eh nicht in Frage.
Das ist doch alles, das hat doch alles mit Smart Home
nichts zu tun.
Für die ganzen Amazon-Fans, okay.
Das meiste hat er hier mit Smart Home.
Was hat denn
Over-Ear-Wire, das Kopfhörer, mit Smart Home zu tun?
Da ist nichts dabei.
Vielleicht, vielleicht von den Shelly.
Wir können mal kurz gucken,
was ist im Shelly-Store.
Wir geben mal kurz Prime Deals.
Shelly.
Mal gucken, ob es da was schönes, günstiges
gibt.
Also wer die Dinger nicht kennt,
wer das nicht kennt,
das sind
kleine Wi-Fi
fähige Relays
im Endeffekt.
Die sind so klein, dass man die in die
beispielsweise in die
Dosen einbauen kann.
Das heißt, du hast da nichts irgendwie an der Wand rumhängen.
Du kannst quasi diesen
das Shelly-Gerät, kannst du quasi
in die Dose einbauen.
Dann schließt du deinen Schalter, deinen
Lichtschalter an das Shelly-Gerät an.
An den Input.
Und beispielsweise
deine Lampe hier
an die Sachen, die geswitcht werden.
Und dann kannst du weiterhin
mit dem Lichtschalter schalten.
Aber auch per Smart Home
über Wi-Fi schalten.
Das ist eigentlich, finde ich, das beste
Upgrade für smarte Beleuchtung.
Weil smarte Beleuchtung, indem
man die Glühbirne austauscht,
oder halt
das Leuchtmittel,
man das ja korrekterweise nennt.
Das ist meistens
blöd, weil, wenn man
einen Lichtschalter hat an der Wand,
man drückt, weil man daran gewöhnt ist,
selbst gerne über den Lichtschalter
und dann sind die Wi-Fi-Dinger ja aus.
Und dann bringt es dann die Smart-Funktion auch nicht mehr.
Oder die Frau,
Freundin, Mutter, Oma, wer auch immer,
die kannst du das ja mit der App nicht
erklären, die drücken dann immer auf den Knopf.
Das heißt, so ein Shelly ist auch
ein super Upgrade
für smarte Beleuchtung,
wenn man einfach nur
alles so lassen möchte, wie es ist,
aber zusätzlich
die Sachen auch über sein Smart Home
steuern können möchte. Also man kann das
weiterhin steuern mit dem normalen Lichtschalter,
aber auch über WLAN,
weil das Licht an der Decke
eben nicht mehr mit dem Schalter
geschaltet wird, sondern der Schalter schaltet den
Shelly und der Shelly schaltet das Licht.
Das heißt, der Shelly ist halt immer online
und kann über Smart Home geschaltet werden.
Also das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Ähm, Shelly kannst du auch
ohne Custom Firmware, ohne Cloud verwenden, ja.
Ja.
Die Shelly Firmware ist auch ziemlich gut.
Also, ne, du schließt das,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie das hier
anschließt, ähm,
da muss man sich mal das Diagramm angucken.
Aber hier
schaltet man höchstwahrscheinlich,
wenn ich das richtig sehe,
hier wird geschaltet, also hier
kommt nicht der Schalter dran, sondern hier kommt
der...
das Licht dran zum Beispiel.
Und wo kommt der Schalter dran?
Hier an 1, ne?
Oder an 2?
Oder kommt der Schalter an S1?
Aber wenn ich mir das Diagramm hier angucke,
dann kommt hier das dran, was geschaltet
wird, nicht der Schalter selbst.
Der Schalter...
Aber dann ist das Diagramm bescheuert, wenn der Schalter
auf S1 kommt.
Ich würde sagen, der Schalter kommt auf...
auf 1 und 2, oder?
Und hier kommt das, was geschaltet
wird, dran.
Wenn ich mir das Diagramm angucke,
ja, was natürlich hier nicht dabei ist,
geil, dann gibt es hier nochmal einen extra kleinen.
Shellys, die
schon in der Unterdose abgebrannt sind.
Ja.
Das liegt aber meistens nicht am Shelley,
würde ich mal behaupten, sondern an jemand,
der das falsch installiert hat.
Ihr müsst das auch nicht selbst installieren, ne?
Ich sage...
Disclaimer, ich würde sowas, wenn ich keine
Ahnung habe, was ich mache,
das nicht selbst einbauen.
Sondern
mir einbauen lassen.
Es gibt Shellys,
die...
die ohne Neutralfunk...
Da gibt es spezielle Shellys.
Bilde ich mir ein.
Das steht dann auch dabei.
Ja.
Aber du hast Recht.
Jede Menge, alle möglichen Varianten.
Analog-Digital-Support
mit
Temperatursensor und allem.
Shelley-Dimmer, was?
Shelley-Uni...
Ah, guck mal, das hat auch gerade einer
im Chat gepostet.
Sowas kann ich wirklich empfehlen.
Ich habe sowas im Keller.
Weil ein Keller
ist irgendwie
nicht so ganz dicht.
Manchmal, wenn es super stark regnet,
dann kommt
Wasser durch die Wände.
Und
das sammelt sich dann in eine Ecke.
Da ist auch ein Ablauf und alles.
Aber ich will das wissen, nur dass halt nicht der Keller irgendwann mal unter Wasser steht.
Da habe ich auch so einen
Überschwemmungssensor.
Gar nicht, wie man das korrekt nennt.
Auf Deutsch.
Kein Hochwassersensor.
So ein Überschwemmungssensor, so ein Wassersensor.
Die Dinger funktionieren total simpel.
Wenn man die mal von unten sehen würde.
Man sieht die aber nicht von unten.
Die haben einfach zwei Kontakte unten.
Und wenn die Kontakte
quasi verbunden werden,
dadurch,
dass Wasser unten drunter läuft, dann löst
der aus.
Wo wohnst du in Hanau?
Liegt
im Main, sagt Google Maps immer.
Ich wohne mitten im Main.
Shelly Button. Intelligente Bluetooth-Taste
zur Aktivierung.
Eine Bluetooth-Taste?
Wie lange hält denn da die Batterie?
Ich würde jetzt eigentlich vermuten,
die Batterie hält da verdammt lange,
weil der ja eigentlich nur Energie braucht
bei einem Knopfdruck.
Da passen keine Shellys rein.
Bluetooth im Hintergrund.
Nee, warum muss da irgendwas im Hintergrund sein?
Der muss eigentlich nur
per Bluetooth ein Signal schicken,
wenn was ist.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass da im Hintergrund
irgendwie was passiert.
Batterie.
Ein Button war defekt, beim anderen die Batterie
direkt leer.
Gibt es da nicht so eine Suchfunktion?
Such mal auf Deutsch.
Jetzt habe ich da
angefangen, Batterie nach
fünf Tagen leer.
Und letztendlich gab es Probleme mit der
Firma über die Batterie.
Das scheint ein ziemlicher
so Hit-and-Miss-Ding zu sein.
Manche finden es geil,
manche finden es kacke.
Ich würde das tatsächlich gerne mal ausprobieren.
So ein Bluetooth-Button ist...
Letztendlich kann man das auch mit irgendeiner
x-beliebigen Fernbedienung machen, aber
ich finde das eigentlich ganz cool.
Alter, das Sechseiten-Shelly gucke ich mir
jetzt nicht an.
Was hat der Chatgeber noch geschickt?
Ah!
Ein Ladegerät.
Von denen hatte ich mal ein Ladegerät.
So ein Quick-Charge-Ladegerät.
Das hat nach zwei Monaten
den Geist aufgegeben.
Ist es nicht explodiert und hat nicht gebrannt oder so?
Aber es ging einfach nicht mehr.
Kann das Quick...ja.
Gun ist doch dieser
Quick-Charge-Standard, oder?
Der sieht hässlich aus.
Wobei, ist das der gleiche?
Nee, nicht ganz.
Nicht ganz der gleiche.
Ich hole jetzt nicht alles durch.
Ich gucke mal hier noch, was die sonst noch
Smarthome-mäßig haben, ob da irgendwas
Spannendes dabei ist.
Messerschärfer. Warum ist das unter
Intelligentes Zuhause?
Worx Hacken...
Also Amazon, ihr fasst Intelligentes
Zuhause ein bisschen zu weit.
Gun ist das Material.
Nein, nein, nein. Gun ist...
Gun, Quick-Charge...
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich dachte, das ist dieser Standard für Quick-Charge.
Okay, dann nicht.
Dann hast du recht.
Der Chat.
Was ist das denn?
Mini-Kettensäge.
Geil.
Das brauche ich.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was ich damit machen soll.
Nee, das brauche ich nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist komplett overrated.
Das braucht man nicht.
Ich habe eine...
Ich habe eine kleine Säge.
Und die sägt wirklich gut.
Das, was man damit sägen kann,
wird mit der kleinen Säge auch wunderbar sägen.
Das braucht man nicht.
Das ist dumme Spielerei.
So eine Klappsäge.
Damit habe ich schon einige Äste abgesägt.
Das geht super easy.
Zack, ab.
Messerschärfe sind anscheinend sehr, sehr scharf da drauf.
So, also.
Ich sehe schon, bei Smart Home kommen wir hier heute nicht weiter.
Was auch immer
das alles jetzt mit Intelligentem Zuhause
zu tun hat, keine Ahnung.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Wir gucken mal die üblichen Sachen.
Eine Sache, die sich immer lohnt.
Amazon eigener Kram.
Amazon eigener Kram
ist eines der wenigen Sachen...
Werkzeuge können wir auch mal gleich gucken.
Amazon eigener Kram
lohnt sich eigentlich immer bei den Prime Days.
Guck mal,
Microsoft hat sogar mittlerweile Handtücher.
Weiß keine, Handtücher sind so
Mikrofaserreinigungstücher.
Ich habe schon
einige Tablets gekauft
bei Prime Days und Prime Deals.
Und sonst was.
Aber ich habe nur noch eins im Einsatz
von den Fire HD Tablets.
Microsoft
kann sein. Manchmal erzähle ich Mist.
Ich meine Amazon.
Also die Amazon eigenen Sachen, die lohnen sich
immer bei den Prime Days.
Manchmal erzähle ich...
Guck mal Leute, ich bin jetzt 40, da setzt manchmal der Kopf aus,
wenn man sowas erzählt.
Also ich habe schon einige Fire HD Tablets gekauft,
aber nur noch eins im Einsatz.
Die waren immer super günstig
bei Prime und Prime Deals und Prime Days.
Sind das jetzt eigentlich Prime Days?
Prime Deal Days
sind das jetzt.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe nur noch eins von den
Fire HDs im Einsatz und das hängt hier oben
im Flur an der Wand.
Der Rest ist abgelöst.
Durch ein bisschen
teurere Tablets, aber die sind einfach
qualitativ besser
und schneller.
Ich benutze günstige
Android Tablets zur Smart Home Steuerung.
Beispielsweise habe ich
im Flur an der Wand was hängen und sowas,
wo man
das Dashboard steuern kann.
Für normale Tablet Nutzung
habe ich ein iPad.
Amazon will Batterien loswerden.
Habe ich sogar schon ein paar mal gekauft,
die Amazon Basic Batterien.
Die gehen in Ordnung.
Die haben ja mittlerweile auch alles, oder?
Hemden,
SD Karten,
Jeans,
Hundecode Beutel,
Handtücher,
Spannbettler. Also Amazon hat wirklich alles.
Mäuse.
Ich weiß nicht mal was das ist.
Ah,
Folie zum Einpacken für Essen.
Gibt es die Katzen noch?
Die hier unten rechts?
Die gibt es leider nicht mehr.
Seit letztem Jahr, so November, Dezember
gibt es die nicht mehr.
Vakuum-Kompressionsbäume.
Wie viel Amazon Basic gibt es eigentlich?
Das ist ja alles.
Spanngurte.
Alimikabel.
Pampers.
Es gibt ja nichts, was es nicht gibt
von Amazon Basic, oder?
Bratpfanne.
Amazon Basic ist wirklich
qualitativ
sehr hochwertiges
Werkzeugset.
Das sehe ich dem schon an.
Auf den ersten Blick, wie hochwertig
das ist.
Kratzbaum.
Hunde haben die auch?
Ach ne, Hundewindel.
Was ist mit Amazon los?
Das ist ja heftig.
Amazon hat ja wirklich einfach
alles mittlerweile als Amazon Basic.
Die machen die Basics.
Wie irgendjemand
vor Jahren auf YouTube mal gesagt hat.
Basics.
Da sind die gut dabei.
Fernseher. Notfallgurt-Schneider.
Das ist auch sowas, wo ich mir echt
überlegen würde, ob es der von Amazon
Basic sein muss.
Black Friday.
Das ist alles extra.
Cyber Week.
Black Friday.
Monat. Prime.
Es gibt laufend irgendwelche
Spezial-Sachen.
Das war aber doch schon, oder?
Ne, ne, Moment.
Das kommt noch.
Das ist
Ende November
irgendwann. Kommt auch noch.
Tacker.
Kabel.
Wirklich ja jeden Scheiß bei Amazon.
Wahnsinn. Hammer.
Nackenhörnchen.
Äh.
Gibt ja echt nichts mehr, was es nicht von Amazon
mittlerweile gibt.
Okay. Den Top 100
haben wir schon geguckt.
Wo gibt es Baumarkt?
Da gibt es auch manchmal ganz gute Sachen.
Prime Day war im Juli. Moment.
Wenn das nicht Prime ist.
Was ist das?
Das ist Prime Deal Days.
Und im Juli war Prime Day.
Das hört ja
Wer soll
Der blickt doch keine Sau mehr durch.
Ist auch egal.
Muss man nicht durchblicken.
Baumarkt. Schauen wir mal.
Staubsauger und Thermostat interessieren mich
gar nicht. Unter Baumarkt hätte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
mal erwartet, dass es Werkzeuge
gibt.
Okay.
Da gibt es schon mal blaue Sachen von Bosch.
Das sind die besseren.
Wie immer.
Der 12 Volt Akkuschrauber Set gibt es gefühlt
jedes Jahr in
zig Kombinationen.
Aber diesmal gibt es auch das 18 Volt Set.
Kennst du eigentlich das Amazon
Preis Addon? Ja, das kenne ich.
Sollte ich vielleicht installieren für solche Sachen?
Ja.
Ja, ja. Das kenne ich.
Das ist sehr sinnvoll, weil gerade was hier steht
ja oftmals überhaupt nicht stimmt.
Da steht ja irgendwie sowas wie Stadt
bla bla bla. Und wenn man sich mal überlegt, was das ist.
Das ist dann irgendwie mal ein Preis,
den irgendwann der Hersteller
vor drei Jahren mal
rausgegeben hat.
Genau hier, UVP.
Kannst komplett vergessen, diesen Preis hier.
Das sagt überhaupt nichts aus.
Das ist auch oftmals, wenn du die gleichen Dinger
suchst. Nennen wir mal beispielsweise das Ding hier.
Wenn du die gleichen Dinger suchst
bei Geizheils. Also hier kostet
200, nicht
Geizheils.
Hier kostet es 239 Euro.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass es das gleiche Zeug
gerade sogar in einem anderen Shop
billiger gibt.
Gerade nicht.
Jetzt ist es tatsächlich
gar kein schlechtes Angebot bei Amazon.
Aber
oftmals sind diese Deals
gar nicht so toll, wie sie auf den ersten Blick aussehen.
Bei Amazon kann man
keine Geräte mehr bestellen, weil das alles geklaut wird.
Also ich habe schon sehr viele
teure Geräte bei Amazon bestellt.
Bis jetzt wurde noch nie was geklaut.
Und
der Typ gibt dir das
auch nur, wenn du das
passende Passwort
hast.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, dass
die Fahrer das nicht klauen können.
Also mir wurde noch nie was geklaut.
Von meinen Amazon
Sachen.
Und ich habe da schon viel teure Sachen bestellt.
Also
bei Werkzeugen würde ich jetzt sagen, jetzt auch nicht so
viel geiler Kram
dabei. Also diese
Dinger können teilweise wirklich ziemlich
gut Value bringen, die Akkuschrauber
Sets, wenn man halt
eines braucht. Ich brauche keins mehr.
Ich habe mir mal vor Jahren so ein Set
hier gekauft.
Man glaubt das
teilweise gar nicht, was in so einem
12 Volt Akkuschrauber für Power
drinsteckt. Ich habe damit schon Löcher
in Wände gebohrt, um Sachen aufzuhängen.
Denkt man teilweise gar nicht,
dass der das hinkriegt.
Natürlich ist das keine Schlagbohrmaschine.
Aber die kleinen
gibt es sogar mit Schlagwerk, wenn man
damit öfters bohren möchte.
Aber das Funst
mein
Accesspoint. Mein Accesspoint an der Wand
habe ich mit dem Ding aufgehängt hier.
Keine Bohrmaschine.
Einfach 12 Volt
Akkuschrauber auf den höchsten Gang
geschaltet, Löcher in die Wand.
Easy.
Wenn es richtig harte Wand draußen
ist, wird es vielleicht
bisschen schwierig. Aber man kommt
sehr weit mit so einem 12 Volt Akkuschrauber.
Professional Kappsäge.
Da hatte ich jetzt noch nicht so das
Verlangen nach einer Kappsäge bis jetzt.
Oder Chat.
Haben wir hier Kappsägen-Enjoyer im Chat?
Die sagen jawohl, endlich mal
so eine Kappsäge daheim.
Akku LED Baustellenlampe.
Ich habe von Bosch Professional auch
eine Baustellenlampe. Die ist nicht so
hell wie das hier. Das ist eine 12 Volt
Lampe.
Aber das ist meine mit Abstand
Lieblings...
Ja, wie soll man sagen? Lieblingslampe ist ein
doofes Wort.
Lieblingstool, wenn ich irgendwas suche.
Ja, wenn ich irgendwie denke, oh
fuck, wo hast du den Schlüssel, deine Uhr
oder so irgendwie runtergefallen.
Dann nehme ich das Licht. Das ist so hell.
Auch die 12 Volt Variante.
Nicht das hier. 12 Volt Variante ist ein bisschen kleiner.
Das Licht.
Mach das an. Das ist so hell.
Du kannst wirklich in jede Ritze
hinter jeden Schrank und so gucken.
Mit der Handylampe
bei weitem nicht so gut wie damit.
Ne, das ist nicht mal...
Not even close. Das ist irgendwie
100 mal heller als das Handy.
Man hat viel mehr LEDs. Das ist einfach nice.
Wenn man Sachen sucht.
Man sollte nicht unbedingt reingucken gerade.
Kältebringer.
Ne, also da ist jetzt auch nichts spannendes dabei.
Was ich ein bisschen
problematisch finde ist,
dass die Sachen so schlecht getrennt sind.
Weil warum ist im Baumarkt
eine kabelgebundene Überwachungskamera?
Das würde ich jetzt bei Smart Home vermuten.
Wenn überhaupt. Oder bei Elektronik.
Weil so findest du die Sachen schlecht.
Das war eine Klimaanlage, ja.
Das war eine Klimaanlage.
Kältebringer.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Auch nicht ganz günstig.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
als 0815K-Knub
würde ich das eh nicht montieren alleine.
Ich habe seit ein paar Jahren
ne Mitsubishi Heavy
Klimaanlage.
Also auch mit Außengerät und
zwei Innengeräte.
Super seit ich die habe. Wirklich.
Das war eines der besten Entscheidungen überhaupt
die Klimaanlage an den Start zu bringen.
Genau. Und außerdem streng genommen
darfst du es nicht mal selbst montieren.
Weil das Zeug auch giftig ist, was da drin ist.
Das hat schon seinen Sinn.
Wassersparender Duschkopf.
Ich hätte tatsächlich gerne einen neuen Duschkopf, aber
nicht zwangsläufig
einen Wassersparenden Duschkopf,
sondern einen, der
ordentlich
Druck hat, aber trotzdem
breit ist.
Mir ist mein Duschkopf zu
zu lasch irgendwie.
Ich hätte gern ein bisschen mehr Druck.
Auf meinem Duschkopf.
Weil ich bin
das noch gewöhnt,
als ich noch hier in der Mietwohnung gewohnt habe,
also vor 2013,
da hatte ich so einen ganz kleinen, billigen
Aldi Duschkopf.
So einen ganz billigen Plastikduschkopf.
Der war aber klein.
Der war nur so klein. Und dadurch, dass der so klein
war, ist das Wasser da wirklich mit einem
richtig harten Druck raus
geflutscht.
Und irgendwie
fand ich das angenehm, weil man ordentlich ein bisschen Wasser
Druck so im Nacken und so im Kopf
und abkriegt.
Und seitdem bin ich hier am gucken,
ob es nicht ja was Gescheites gibt.
Sowas, wo ein bisschen
breiter ist, wo schön
breit Wasser rauskommt, aber auch mit ordentlich Druck.
Liegt es da nicht an einem Wasserdruck
im Haushalt gemeint, nicht am Duschkopf?
Ich glaube, der Wasserdruck ist schon
okay.
Ist die Frage, auf welche Fläche immer das verteilt
wird. Ne, das geht.
Guck dir mal an. Das muss
auch anders funktionieren. Guck dir mal
so einen Kärcher-Hochdruckreiniger an.
Da musst du auch nur ein bisschen Wasser reinmachen.
Und das Wasser, was rauskommt, kommt da mit richtig
viel Power raus.
So, ich bräuchte quasi
einen Duschkopf, der ein bisschen wie ein
Hochdruckreiniger ist, nur nicht ganz so
hohen Druck. Ich weiß, dass das keinen
Sinn ergibt, ja. Ich weiß, was so ein Hochdruckreiniger
macht. Aber sowas wär nice.
Gibt es... Okay, wir müssen
jetzt mal was suchen. Wir müssen mal suchen, ob es
gescheites Werkzeug bei Prime Day gibt. Gibt's was
von Vera? Prime Deals.
Nein, gibt es... Ah!
Das ist nice. Das hab ich
auch. Ah, Moment. Das ist...
Ne. Das hab ich nicht.
Das... Ne, ne. Meins sieht anders aus.
Ich glaub, das ist was anderes.
Aber so ähnlich. So ähnlich hab ich auch eins.
Das ist sehr pog.
Das ist alles.
Ne, gibt doch noch ein bisschen mehr. Der Bit-Halter
ist mega nice. Davon hab ich drei Stück.
Die werden immer geused, wenn man
was braucht. Der Bit-Halter ist
richtig pog. Weiß ich,
ob die ein Video dazu haben? Naja.
Ich hab jetzt eigentlich gehofft, ihr
zeigt mal die Funktion.
Anstatt den Bit-Halter
an sich.
Wie der Bit-Halter aussieht.
Müssen wir uns das jetzt nicht in einem Video angucken.
Ja, es ist... Im Prinzip ist es einfach.
Du machst das rein, dann ziehst du das zurück
und dann kannst du wieder raus machen. Aber den
find ich sehr pog. Den hab
ich dreimal und überall im Einsatz.
Digitales
Ortungsgerät.
Magnetisch. Ja, ja.
Also der
Bit-Halter ist...
Wobei. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Vielleicht ist
er ein bisschen magnetisch, dass du es einfacher rein kriegst.
Aber ansonsten
hält der durch
mechanischen Clips.
Das Clip da rein
und dann musst du es zurückziehen,
dass es wieder raus geht.
Vielleicht ein bisschen
magnetisch kann sein. Aber das auf jeden Fall
wird das nicht gehalten durch Magnete.
Der hält das richtig fest.
Da kriegst du nicht raus. Also er hält
das auf jeden Fall nicht magnetisch.
Okay, so. Gucken wir mal.
Haben wir noch ein paar andere?
Vielleicht haben wir
ein paar Schraubendreher-Sets.
Oh!
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Aber da hat man was.
Also da kann man sich zumindest drauf verlassen,
was Schraubendreher und sonst was
angeht, dass da was Gescheites drin ist.
Das wäre mir
vielleicht ein bisschen zu
übertrieben.
Zumal man das meiste davon gar
nicht oft
braucht. Aber das ist ein
guter Hersteller. Die machen gescheites Zeug.
Du hast ein was?
Ein Endura Fit Universal.
Das Ding?
Duschkopf.
Jetzt lasst euch übrigens nicht von dem Preis
abschrecken.
Das ist gar nicht jetzt irgendwie übertrieben
oder so. Also da ist ja wirklich jede Menge
dabei und es ist qualitativ auch wirklich
gut, was da am Start ist. Also ich meine,
die werden das nicht alles selbst
herstellen. Da wird bestimmt auch ein bisschen was
gerendert sein. Gerade bei den ganzen
Zangen bin ich mir nicht so sicher, was
da alles von denen ist oder
keine Ahnung. Und auch hier dieses andere Zeug.
Aber zumindest bei den Schraubendrehern
und sonst was ist das von denen
und die bauen wirklich gescheites Zeug.
Also das ist kein Kack-Hersteller.
Das kostet halt auch ein bisschen was.
Welchen hast du da?
Ach, bei Amazon.
Das kauft man einmal und nie wieder.
In der Theorie
ja, aber ich kann dir aus eigener
Erfahrung sagen, als jemand, der gerne Werkzeug
kauft,
ich habe auch durchaus die
ein oder anderen Sachen doppelt mittlerweile.
Kann ich mich gar nicht entscheiden.
Und ich habe auch ein paar
unsinnige Sachen, die ich so gut wie nie brauche.
Aber wenn ich sie brauche, bin ich happy.
Ich habe mir zum Beispiel mal ein
das Vera Joker Set gekauft,
aber nicht das
billige, sondern
das teure mit den
mit der Ratschenfunktion.
Sind das die mit der
Ratschenfunktion?
Ja.
Was auch immer bei Amazon hier gerade verkehrt läuft
mit dem Bild, keine Ahnung.
Aber ja, so ungefähr so viel hat
das gekostet.
Und ich brauche das nicht oft.
Aber das fühlt sich so geil an.
Das Werkzeug
von denen.
Und wenn ich es mal brauche, bin ich super happy,
dass ich es habe.
Die sind richtig geil, die Dinger.
Du hast einmal
hier die normale Maulschüssel, auf der anderen Seite
hast du was mit Ratschenfunktion.
Du setzt das quasi an.
Hier sieht man es.
Die zeigen mal wieder nichts.
Du setzt das im Endeffekt an die Ratschenfunktion.
Super, nichts davon
zeigen sie.
Du setzt das hier quasi drauf und dann kannst du so
ohne abzusetzen
Ich sammle nicht Werkzeuge,
ich habe aber, ich kaufe gerne
Werkzeuge und ich habe gerne
für jede passende
Anwendung das passende Werkzeug da.
Was nicht immer der Fall ist, aber mittlerweile zum
Teil. Aber natürlich ergibt sich bei
manchen Käufen auch,
das ist übrigens auch super das Ding.
Bei manchen Käufen ergibt sich halt auch die ein oder andere Überschneidung.
Kannst du einen Drehmomentschlüssel
empfehlen? Ich habe
zwei Stück. Ich habe
für die meisten Sachen, für die großen Sachen habe
ich tatsächlich den
20 bis
hatten die nicht noch
einen mittleren?
Also ich habe einen fetten Vera Drehmomentschlüssel
und einen kleinen
No Name Drehmomentschlüssel.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich hatte einen mit
dann sowas hier wahrscheinlich.
20 bis 100
Ich habe einen kleinen für die
für
1 bis 20 und dann habe ich den fetten
Vera für 20 bis 100
Den brauche ich nicht so oft,
der ist schon echt massiv.
Aber der ist nice.
Und das Ding hier, auch wenn es
nicht im Angebot ist, das kann ich euch
wirklich empfehlen.
Wenn ihr einfach irgendwas sucht, so nach
dem Motto, ey ich will was haben,
was ich mir irgendwo in die Schublade
legen kann und wenn ich mal was brauche,
dann habe ich zu
95%
das passende, dann
das Ding hier.
Sucht nach Tool Check Plus.
Das Ding ist wirklich nice.
Ihr habt die gängigen
Nüsse und ihr habt alle gängigen
Bits. Ihr habt eine kleine
Mini Ratsche dabei und einen kleinen Mini Schraubendreher
und einen Bit Halter.
Ja, ich meine mit diesen kleinen
Dingern hier,
drehst jetzt keine Autoräder
fest, wobei das reicht dir
wahrscheinlich auch 13 nicht.
Aber für alles im Haushalt,
also ihr habt seit mit diesem
einen Ding für 90%
der Fälle, wo irgendwas geschraubt werden
muss im Haushalt, eigentlich
gewappnet.
Manchmal ist es ein bisschen
fummelig, weil das ist ja nur im Prinzip
ein kleiner Schraubendrehergriff
mit einer Bit Aufnahme
dran. Manchmal hätten wir schon gerne
was mit ein bisschen
länger
Du machst den Schraubendreher
in den Griff, machst den Bit Halter rein, den Bit Halter
vorne, machst dann das Bit.
Ist manchmal ein bisschen fummelig,
ein bisschen klein, aber
wenn man sonst nichts hat
und einfach was braucht, wo du 90%
deiner Schraubdinger
mit abfackeln kannst, dann das Ding hier.
Das ist auch super was, was man sich beispielsweise
in die Fahrradtasche stecken
kann, wobei
das reicht ein bisschen übertrieben, weil
eher was für Motorradfahrer
weil Fahrrad, ganz ehrlich,
beim Fahrrad brauchst du eigentlich
zwei Sachen
Du brauchst da dein
Schnellspann-Dings
ich hab vergessen wie das heißt
dieser Schnellspanngriff da
wie auch immer der heißt
und du brauchst am besten irgendein
Multitool mit ein paar
gängigen
Torx
wie heißt das?
Sechskant oder so
Gibt es von Wera ein Fahrradset?
Also ich hab mir mal irgendwann fürs Fahrrad
ja sowas hier in der Richtung
ich hab mir mal so ein Parktool
Fahrradding
gekauft
und das hab ich bei mir in der Tasche drin
da hab ich für alle Schrauben
vom Schaltwerk hinten
wenn man mal ein bisschen
was einstellen muss
bis Lenker
das ist für alles was dabei
ist zwar ein bisschen hakelig mit diesem Multitool
aber es ist klein, es wiegt nicht viel
das hab ich bei mir im Fahrrad einfach immer dabei
achja und zwei Stück davon
für die Reifen
Duravit Universal Duschkopf
hab ich bei Amazon gesucht und man findet
nix
oder den da?
ist das, ist das, welchen hast du davon?
Eine Stabbrause
Irgendwas anderes
gibt es denn, oder?
Ne, den da hast du wahrscheinlich, oder?
Du hast geschrieben mit dem Duschkopf
Frozen Chicken
welchen davon?
falls du noch da bist
der erste
guck mal gibt es sogar ein Prime Angebot
der hier
und da kommt das auch mit ordentlich Power raus
ja
und auf welche
Stufe hast du das eingestellt?
weil mein Duschkopf hat auch so eine Funktion
dass man das in kleiner einstellen kann
und da kommt das auch mit mehr Druck raus
aber das ist mir dann schon zu klein
eigentlich suche ich sowas
wie ich früher in der alten Wohnung hatte
so einen billigen 3,50€ Aldi Duschkopf
wo das mit ordentlich Wumms rauskommt
Wasser sparen, ich will kein Wasser sparen
ich will ordentlichen Druck auf dem Duschkopf haben
guck mal Amazon denkt
ich will Duschköpfe kaufen
so dann lasst uns mal gucken
was ist bei
äh ne alle Angebote
was ist bei Computer Software
was es denn wieder für SSDs gibt
weil SSDs lohnen sich auch oftmals
das ist wahrscheinlich bei Computer und Zubehör
ne
Kategorie
mittlerer Modus
ich glaube ich bestelle mir mal so einen hier
einfach zum ausprobieren
da gibt es ein SanDisk extrem 4TB
brauchen wir nicht
da habe ich tatsächlich noch 2 Stück von rumliegen
nicht 4TB nur 2
ich habe eigentlich genug SSD Speicher
aber in der Regel lohnt sich
immer SSDs kaufen bei Primelace
da gibt es oftmals gute Angebote
Notebooks Notebooks Drucker
nie wieder Leute
ich sage es euch
nie wieder
hole ich mir einen Tintenstrahldrucker
Tintenstrahldrucker sind der größte Dreck
den es gibt
ich habe umgestellt vor einer Weile
auf einen Farblazer Drucker
auf einen Farblazer Multifunktionsgerät
also quasi auf einen Farblazer
mit Multifunktionsgerät
also Drucken und Scannen im Endeffekt
Kopieren ist ja quasi eine Kombination aus Scannen
und Drucken mit Dokumenteneinzug
wo du auch direkt auf einen USB Stick
und sowas scannen kannst
das hat sich gelohnt
das war ein bisschen teurer
aber kein Rumgefrickel mehr
mit Tintenkopfreinigen
Druckerhersteller die ja mittlerweile
theoretisch kann der übrigens auch faxen
habe ich aber nicht angeschlossen
kein komisches Tintenkopfreinigen
mehr wenn man es mal ein Dreivierteljahr
nicht benutzt hat aber jetzt mal was braucht
kein Hersteller der der Meinung ist
Perfume wäre dir
dir zu verbieten
deinen Drucker zu verwenden
da gibt es ja immer wieder so Horrorgeschichten
gerade bei HP
nie wieder, nie wieder kaufe ich mir einen Tintenstrahldrucker
größter Schrott überhaupt Tintenstrahldrucker
kauft euch einmal richtig
ein ordentliches
Farblazer Multifunktionsgerät
und gut ist
anstatt es laufen irgendwelche Tintenstrahlkacke
es sei denn
ihr wollt Fotos oder sowas
aber wer druckt Fotos?
heutzutage mehr
niemand braucht Tintenstrahldrucker
also ich hab ein
gucken ob es den vielleicht sogar gibt
bei Amazon heute
aber meiner ist natürlich wie gesagt
hab ich auch schon wieder zwei
ein Brother MFC
L37
griffiger griffiger Name
by the way
CDW das Ding
habe ich mir vor zwei Jahren gekauft
so
das mag jetzt Oversized aussehen
aber ohne Scheiß
es funktioniert einfach
es hat noch nie irgendwelche Mucken gemacht
die letzten zwei Wochen
und der Scheiß tut
und das ist das was ich bei einem Multifunktionsgerät brauche
das soll gefälligst scannen
wenn ich will
das soll kopieren
das soll drucken
das soll genug Papier drinnen haben
was es hier auch aufnehmen kann
das ganze gibt es übrigens auch ohne Fax
wir brauchen Fax
kann Farbe drucken
Dokumente sehen super aus
meine Fotos sehen halt nicht geil aus
aber okay für Dokumente
und so vollkommen in Ordnung
überhaupt kein Problem
ohne Scheiß soll das Ding kann ich empfehlen
gibt es nicht, gibt es gerade nicht im Angebot
gibt bestimmt auch kleinere Variante
aber das war die beste Entscheidung überhaupt
einfach mal einen ordentlichen Drucker zu kaufen
und bei meinem Druckaufkommen
hält der Toner da drin
wahrscheinlich auch
bis ich sterbe irgendwann mal
bin ich eine Topdrucker Marke geworden
in dem sie einfach nicht schlimmer geworden sind
gerade was HP bei den Tintenstrahldingern abzieht
also das Ding kann ich empfehlen
macht null Probleme
WLAN geht übers WLAN
und geht einfach
es tut einfach
nie wieder Tintenstrahldrucker Leute
größter Schrott überhaupt
ja natürlich
Laserdrucker sind prinzipiell unter Linux
ja eigentlich gar kein Problem
du brauchst doch nicht mal einen extra Treiber
du brauchst doch eine normale Standard
Posts ne wie heißt das
Ghost Script
Tempel für den Drucker
der kann alle möglichen Druckstandards
wie man Drucker ansteuert
Funst
CUPS ist aber gerade recht anfällig
ja da gab es irgendwelche Sicherheitsprobleme
in den letzten Wochen in CUPS habe ich gelesen
ich weiß aber gar nicht was da gewesen ist
bei CUPS
das nur am Rande mitbekommen
so es gibt eine
2TB SSD
ok
jede Menge Notebooks
ein Copilot Plus PC
ist ja sehr beliebt wie es aussieht
scheint ja sehr beliebt zu sein
und nicht einer gekauft bisher
Copilot Plus das ist dieser Krempel den wir vorhin hatten
also
Copilot Plus PC ist das mit Windows Recall
die euch eure
Windows Session komplett aufzeichnen
und ich weiß was damit passiert
Iron Wolf
Seagate Festplatte
6TB
6TB ist glaube ich gerade
ein ziemlich guter Spot
Preis-Leistungs mäßig
wobei ich glaube sogar
10 oder 12TB sind aktuell
die Preis-Leistungs
Klasse
also die
Cent pro Gigabyte
glaube ich 10 oder 12TB
gerade am besten
noch mehr SSDs
ich habe schon mal jemanden von euch verwendet
die springt mir jedes mal ins Auge
wenn ich mir Apple Mäuse angucke
und ich denke mir immer
das Ding sieht null ergonomisch aus
aber bei Apple Produkten ist es ja manchmal so
man muss das Kram ausprobieren
dann ist es doch nicht so schlecht
das Ding sieht für mich null ergonomisch aus
und abfuck zu benutzen
was sollen die 6TB denn kosten
gucken wir mal
150€
du hast hier 4x4TB
willst du irgendwelche Raid Geschichten machen
denk dran
wenn du Raid 5 machen willst
oder überleg dir immer gut
ob du Raid 5 machen willst
also bei 4 Festplatten
geht das mit Raid 5 noch
aber bei mehr würde ich mir Gedanken machen
also Raid 5
ist das was in der Regel läuft
unter so quasi Parity
mit einer Platte
lieber Raid 1
nein Raid 1 ist vielleicht nicht so gut
bei 4 Festplatten
dann hast du ja die Kapazität von einer Platte
dann kannst du Raid 10 zum Beispiel machen
weil das auch nicht so viel besser ist
also bei 4 Festplatten
ist ein Raid 5 okay
bei 4 Festplatten ist ein Raid 5
ein guter Kompromiss finde ich
ganz ehrlich
ich würde mir tatsächlich überlegen gar keinen Raid zu machen
sondern
ähm
einfach große Disk
und das die Daten eben noch da
kein Raid 0
ich würde keinen Raid 0 machen
dann musst du Disk machen
wo die Daten auf unterschiedliche Platten geschrieben werden
wenn eine Platte weg ist sind nur die Daten auf einer Platte weg
Backup musst du so und so machen
und wenn du gegen Ausfälle gesichert sein möchtest
ja dann mach einen Raid 10
im Prinzip ist ja ein Raid 10
quasi ein
Leute was ist ein Raid 10
ist ein Raid 10 2 Raid 1 und dann ein Stripe drüber
oder 2 Stripes und ein Raid 1 drüber
wer hat
wer hier High IQ Fachinformatiker
der aufgepasst hat
S0
dann 2 mal 1
ok 2 Raid 1 und 1 Stripe
ja
das würde ich wahrscheinlich machen mit 4 Platten
oder
wenn du ganz ausfallsicher sein willst
du kannst auch 2 unabhängige Raid 1 voneinander machen
wenn du ausfallsicher bist
ist natürlich ein Raid 1 mit 4 Platten
dann hast du aber nur die Kapazität von einer
Raid 5 ist durchaus ok
kannst du auch ein Raid 6 machen
dann verlierst du aber 2 Platten
Raid 10 ist nur gut bei 2 Platten
Raid 10 geht überhaupt nicht mit 2 Platten
ähm
ganz ehrlich
ich würde gar keinen Raid machen
ich würde einfach
die Discs zusammenpacken
nicht Raid 0 wohlgemerkt
deswegen sage ich ja das sind 4 Platten
deswegen würde ich auch wenn ein Raid dann
Raid 10 oder aber
ich persönlich würde gar keinen Raid machen
ich würde die Discs einfach als unterschiedliche Discs
verwenden ich würde die halt so
da gibt es ja können ja
Lastgeräte kannst du ja alle
Festplatten zusammenfassen lassen
aber wohlgemerkt zu keinem Raid 0
weil Raid 0 bedeutet
die Dateien werden verteilt auf allen 4 Platten gespeichert
und wenn eine Platte kaputt geht ist alles weg
ich meine wirklich die Platten einzeln
verwenden unter der Haube
aber halt nur als großes Laufwerk anzuzeigen
das können eigentlich alle Lastgeräte
und
regelmäßig Backup machen
bei 4 Festplatten
ist die Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit noch nicht so hoch
und
du verkraftest im Heimbereich ohne Probleme
auch mal eine Downtime
von ein paar Stunden wo du was
wo du vielleicht wieder was zurück kopieren musst von einem Backup
ich würde auf jeden Fall ein Backup machen
von den wichtigen Sachen
ja wenn du da wenn du da
wenn du sagen wir mal hier
du hast nur 2-3 wichtige Sachen
der Rest ist Schrott der kann weg
ist auch egal dann machst du nur davon ein Backup
B-Cache FS wird gerade
geflamed Linux technisch habe ich gehört
ne nicht Merge FS
gibt es auch
ich meine so ein ganz normales wie nennt sich das denn
also weder RAID
ich meine nicht RAID 0
es gibt doch so einen Modus das kann jedes NAS
wo du einfach alle Platten zusammenfasst
zu einer großen
J-Bot genau das meine ich
ein logisches Laufwerk aber ohne Striping
also sprich
wenn ein Laufwerk kaputt geht dann sind nur die Daten weg
die auf diesem Laufwerk drauf waren
also da muss ich sagen ich habe mir das ein bisschen durchgelesen
ich muss sagen ich bin auf
Linus Seite
also die Antworten
von B-Cache FS
die würden mich als Maintainer auch hart triggern
aber wenn du RAID machen willst mach RAID 10
RAID 10 kann auch fast jedes NAS
können wir das
bitte alle nochmal in TB-Byte
ist es TB-Byte oder Tab
ne ist TB-Byte
berechnen
ne können wir nicht
weil nach wie vor niemand
in TB-Byte rechnet
auch wenn das einfacher ist
und jeder rechnet
in TB
nur dass manche 1000 und manche nach wie vor
1024 rechnen
oder ist es TB-Byte ach keine Ahnung
die IHK macht das sehr gerne
sogar schon in meiner Abschlussprüfung damals
aber in meiner Abschlussprüfung war es einem noch selbst überlassen
ob man 1000 oder 1024
rechnet Leute ich weiß schon gar nicht
aus dem Kopf was richtig ist
TB
ist 1024
und Terabyte
ist 1000 oder
oder umgedreht
ja ne
es ist
unintuitiv weil jeder bei
Terabyte an 1024 denkt
aber streng genommen ist Terabyte
ja wirklich 1000 Bytes
oder nicht 1000 Bytes stimmt nicht
1000 Gigabytes
und ein TB-Byte sind
1024 Gigabyte
aber niemand
das befindet eigentlich kaum einer
sagen eigentlich alle immer Terabyte
ganz ehrlich die gängigste Sache
die ich kenne ist dass die Leute sagen
Terabyte Gigabyte Kilobyte
was auch immer und meinen 1024
warum hat sich das eigentlich jemand
ausgedacht naja
weil
streng genommen diese
Bezeichnung Kilomega
und sowas ja eigentlich immer
1000 sind
immer 1000 mehr
das sind überall 1000 mehr
nur das ist halt
Binary mäßig
irgend jemand auf die Idee gekommen ist
ach komm ne das sind nicht 1000 sondern
1024 das heißt überall anders
sind das immer 1000
aber IT mäßig waren es dann
1024 und
irgendwann haben die Hersteller angefangen
entweder 1000 oder 1024
zu nehmen je nachdem
was sich Marketing technisch besser eignet
und dann haben sie halt gesagt
ok wir machen noch TB
und Mebi und Kibi
und was es nicht alles gibt um dann wirklich
zu sagen ok das ist 1024
und wenn dann dran steht Kilo
und Terra und Mega das ist dann
wirklich immer nur 1000
also ganz ehrlich
jeder den ich kenne
der Kilo Byte sagt
der meint
also sind nicht viele Sachen dabei
ach guck mal meine alte Maus gibt es wieder
die jetzt aber
anders heißt
die habe ich auf der Arbeit die Maus
Alter was geht bei der Musik ab
auf der Arbeit habe ich die mittlerweile
meine
Kombi auf der Arbeit ist
eine
Ducky One Skyline Tastatur
und eine
Logitech G501
gab es auch noch eine
G501
mal
wie heißt die Pro Toy Score
habe ich noch
ne ok 502
ja meine
Office Kombination
meine Kombination
daheim ist tatsächlich eine
spezielles Logitech Maus mit einem
Maus Pad
was die Maus auflädt
hätte ich auch nicht für möglich gehalten
dass ich da mal so drauf schwöre
aber das ist eine super angenehme
nice Kombination
die auch für Gaming gut ist
habt ihr freie Hardwarewahl
also bei Maus und Tastatur darfst du
anschließen was du willst ja
Notebook kriegst du gestellt
und wir haben auch keine freie Betriebssystem
leider keine freie Betriebssystemwahl
was aber nicht so schlimm ist weil
du kannst mir auf
meiner VM installieren kann was ich will
das du machst 100% Home Office
ne ich mach nicht 100% Home Office
ich bin einen Tag die Woche in Frankfurt im Büro
im Durchschnitt zumindest
ja ich muss Windows benutzen auf dem Notebook
aber glücklicherweise
habe ich in der Cloud eine fette Linux
VM wo ich root bin
und über ein Proxy auch ins Internet
komme und sowas
also alles gut
warum gab es eigentlich dieses Jahr wieder einen SSD Boom
das weiß ich nicht ich wusste noch nicht
mal dass es einen gab
aha
RGB RAM
ich
glaube hab ich den
hab ich nicht sogar den RAM bei mir im Rechner
ist hier mein Rechner vielleicht
nein was da vielleicht
ja hab ich für einen RAM
ne hab ich nicht
hab ich nicht
ich hab Gskill
Gskill RGB RAM
Gskill Trident
Z5 RGB
aber muss RGB
Archilux in deiner Cloud
ne ganz normales Ubuntu ist das
hast du mal Hyperland probiert
ja sogar im Stream
leider läuft Hyperland
in der VM nicht richtig
sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch schon mehr
Hyperlandet
ich hab mir einen extra Mini PC gekauft
um das mal ordentlich aus
was hab ich jetzt gemacht
ordentlich auszuprobieren
der jetzt btw hier rumgammelt
der Mini PC da steht hier neben mir
und ich hab
einfach sinnlose Geld
Geld verpulvert er
ich glaube ich mach da wieder ne Emulationskiste draus
weil die alte Emulationskiste hab ich ja meinem Vater geschenkt
mit Linux Mint
drauf
und die benutzt er jetzt
Fickwot
geiler Name
und welche SSD benutzt du so
Fickwot
manche Namen sind echt in unterschiedlichen Sprachen
nicht so dolle
Qvo gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile ne
Qvo 4TB
hat das Samsung jetzt mal irgendwie auf die Reihe gekriegt
ja
hat ja ewig gedauert
ne 8TB Evo gibt es aber immer noch oder
oh ne ne ne gibt es nicht
Qvo 8TB
gibt es nur
aber es gibt endlich mal ne 4TB
Evo das hat lange gedauert
wofür steht Evo
das sind die Flashspeicher
ich kann dir nicht genau sagen was der Unterschied zwischen Qvo und Evo ist
ich weiß nur dass die
Speicher
die Zellen
wie nennt man das
die SSD Chips
dass die irgendwie
bei den Evo Kisten
nicht mehrere
States quasi
also die Qvo Dinger
müssen irgendwie mehrere States
speichern
pro Zelle
und sind deswegen ein bisschen langsamer
und halt auch billiger
und die Evo Dinger
machen das nicht
die sind halt deswegen teurer
weil sie irgendwie mehr Zellen
oder fragt mich
die Evo Dinger sind in der Regel ein bisschen besser
ich kann euch nicht genau sagen was der Unterschied ist
es ist irgendwas in der Richtung
von dem was ich gesagt hab
aber ich hab keine Ahnung wie das genau ist
andersrum ist es
ok
wie gesagt ich sag doch ich hab keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf
Qvo ist QLC
also 4-fache Bit Speicherung per Zelle
und TLC ist 3-fache Bit Speicherung pro Zelle
dann ist es nicht 2-fach und 3-fach sondern 4-fach und 3-fach
so genau kenn ich mich da aus dem Kopf nicht aus
was SSDs angeht
ein 32 Zoll Gaming Monitor
ok
was macht ihr zum Gaming Monitor
165 Hertz vielleicht
G-Sync kompatibel
ok
165 Hertz ist schonmal gut
aber
mein nächster Monitor
der wird
OLED
und 240 Hertz
drunter
mach ich es nicht
weil ich hab jetzt schon 240 Hertz
für mich ist das nächste logische Upgrade OLED
nicht 360 Hertz
also
ihr kennt mich ihr wisst dass ich gerne
quasi
das schnellste an Technik
und Wiederholrad
wie geht aber
ganz ehrlich der Unterschied von 240 Hertz
zu 360 Hertz
hat sich ja auch im professionellen Gaming
Segment nicht wirklich
durchgesetzt also
dann lieber OLED
das
Pestiko habe ich noch nie gehört was das sein soll
für Overwatch
ne Overwatch fasse ich nicht mehr an
merkt man das überhaupt
also den Unterschied von
60 auf 144 Hertz
behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal
den merkt
jeder der minimales
Gespür für sowas hat
also meine Mutter zum Beispiel merkt den Unterschied nicht
die erkennt aber auch den Unterschied
zwischen 15 und 60 FPS
nicht oder FPS ist ja falsch
Hertz Wiederholrate
aber du brauchst natürlich auch
ein Game was das bringt nichts wenn du
240 Hertz Monitor hast und nur 30 FPS
jetzt
bevor jetzt die Leute kommen in der Theorie schon
ja theoretisch
ne kann das trotzdem ein bisschen schneller sein
weil die Frames dann quasi
sobald sie fertig gerendert sind auch angezeigt werden
aber in der Regel brauchst du auch
hohe Bildwiederholrate dass du eben
eine hohe Wiederholfrequenz ordentlich ausnutzen kannst
also
also fangen wir mal an
30 zu 60
merkt sage ich jetzt einfach mal jeder
so
60 zu 144
Hertz merkt auch
jeder der ein bisschen
Gaming Erfahrung ein bisschen Gespür dafür hat
ich bin überrascht
wenn jemand den Unterschied zwischen 60
und 144 nicht merkt
der Unterschied von 144 zu 240
der ist
deutlich subtiler
das ist nicht so wie
wenn du von 60 auf 144 hoch steigst
das ist die Offenbarung
das ist so wie ich sehe bei Kameraschwenks
noch Inhalte von dem Bild
von 144
auf 240 ist so
oh ja die Inhalte sind ein bisschen crisper
ein bisschen schärfer
bei schnellen Kameraschwenks
240 auf 360
hab ich persönlich ehrlich gesagt erst gar nicht ausprobiert
ich glaube aber nicht
dass es das wert ist
alter Amazon man
the fuck
ja klar warst du langsamer
natürlich warst du langsamer
das ist ja kein Wunder dass du mit 60 Hertz langsamer bist
als mit 144 Hertz
das findest du ja so
du drückst ja hier sobald es grün wird
wird dir gedrückt
und allein schon dadurch dass es schneller rendert
bist du schneller
und man darf nicht vergessen
1 durch 60
16 Millisekunden
ist glaube ich ein Bild bei 60
was sind wir 30
erzähl ich jetzt Mist Leute
16 Millisekunden
braucht man quasi pro Bild
bei 60
60 Hertz
guck mal bei 144
sind es schon 7 Millisekunden
und bei 240
da sind das nur noch 4
und da sieht man halt so ok
das hat irgendwie so mal irgendwann
irgendwann macht es das nicht mehr so fest
das sind quasi nur
guck mal der Unterschied von
240 zu 360
das ist halt
einfach nur sind
ich war 2
1,5 Millisekunden
Unterschied
ne das hier sind
Millisekunden sind ja 1000
also sind das hier 2 Millisekunden
also das ist halt nicht mehr so krass
so und deswegen weil das hier schneller rendert
weil das hier schneller rendert
sollen wir mal testen
dass der Boomer noch auf die Reihe kriegt
Reaction Time Leute
Finger aufwärmen
Reaction Time
ah schon ups
das habe ich nicht geguckt
das ist nicht Bad Leute
es gibt nicht viele Leute die
schnellere Reaction Time haben
also für meinen Boomer
alter von 40 ist das super
ich weiß Selbstlob stinkt
aber das ist wirklich nicht schlecht
und gerade für 40 ist das nicht schlecht
selbst CS Pro Gamers
haben nur ein bisschen weniger
und die sind 20
oder 25
ich bin 40
die meisten Leute sind mit 18 auch langsam
guck mal
Durchschnitts Reaction Time 20
bis 250 Millisekunden
Computer kommt noch oben drauf
also das ist nicht schlecht
das ist echt ein Übel
und wenn ich ein bisschen übe
und mich da voll drauf konzentriere
dann komme ich bestimmt relativ konsistent so oft
diese Dinger
das ist echt nicht schlecht
gerade für 40 ist das voll in Ordnung
richtig Agile
korrekt
Waschmaschine Empfehlung
das ist eine gute Frage
Trockene Empfehlung kann ich dir geben
und jetzt mit 60 Hertz
ja dann ist man
das kannst du
hau einfach nochmal 16 Millisekunden drauf
kann ich eine Trockene Empfehlung geben
ich habe nämlich einen Trockene
am Start
gerade 2 Millisekunden
ja da hast du Glück gehabt
finde ich nicht mehr
wie heißt denn das wenn das nicht Trockene heißt
ich suche einfach nach Wäsche
Wäscheklammer finde ich geil
hier
2014 habe ich einen gekauft
Wäschetrockner
den kann ich dir nicht empfehlen
den gibt es nicht mehr
und was ich 2014 gekauft habe
ist sicherlich jetzt nicht mehr der neueste Scheiße
du hast nie den Sinn in einem Trockene gesehen
ja
kannst du die Wäsche schlecht nass in den
Fang schmeißen
kannst du auch draußen aufhängen
aber das ist im Winter auch immer suckt
Waschmaschine Empfehlung
weiß ich nicht was wir da für eine haben
keine Ahnung
aufhängen suckt
genau wir brauchen schon Toaster
einfach ins freie legen
oder noch besser
einfach
gut werden
und dann
den Toaster irgendwie an den
Home Trainer dran
und dann einfach mal schön konstant mit 800 Watt
für eine Minute treten
by the way
das werdet ihr auch mit viel Übung
wahrscheinlich nicht schaffen
oder habt ihr auch kostenlos getoastet
gut kostenlos kann man es nicht nennen
weil ihr müsst ja was essen und trinken dafür
und der Körper
ist vom Wirkungsgrad her echt nicht gut
aber wenn ihr es schafft
mit einem Fahrrad einen Toaster zu betreiben
dann habt ihr ordentlich was in den Beinen
weil du musst den Toaster
eine Minute, eineinhalb Minuten
musst du toasten
und Toaster brauchst du 7-800 Watt
und ich kann euch sagen
ich kann
so 350
also in Spitzen
kann ich ein bisschen über 400 Watt treten
aber nur kurz
so 350 Watt
für 30 Sekunden packe ich
ich weiß das ist nicht super krass
aber
es ist heftiger
als es sich anhört
einen Toaster zu betreiben mit dem Fahrrad
da gab es dieses Video
ja genau
wobei der Typ noch einen heftigeren
Output hat
der hat aber seine Probleme das über die Minute zu fahren
Max
was machst du eigentlich mit deinem Geld
das ist eine sehr gute Frage
geht das alles ins Zocken ein
das wenigste davon geht ins was soll ich denn
was was da müsste ich irgendwelche koreanischen
Pay2Win Spiele spielen und da irgendwie tausende Euro reinbuttern
oder sparst du viel um nicht mehr arbeiten zu müssen
ähm
also
ich spare
relativ viel das liegt
nicht primär daran
weil ich sag ich will nicht mehr arbeiten müssen
da bin ich auch nix dagegen wenn ich nicht mehr arbeiten muss
das liegt primär daran
dass ich eigentlich einen relativ genügsamen
Lebensstil hab und es wenig
gibt wo ich sag oh da muss ich jetzt unbedingt
mein Geld reinbuttern
ja
ich kauf mir ab und zu was wenn ich der Meinung bin das ist ja
mal wieder an der Zeit oder das will ich haben
beispielsweise neues Fahrrad oder neuen Fernseher
oder neuen Computer alle paar Jahre
da wird dann auch immer was richtig gutes und teures
gekauft aber ansonsten
hab ich ein recht
ja ich mein ich bin jetzt kein
Frugalist oder wie man das nennt
aber ansonsten hab ich
recht wenige Sachen die
Geld kosten
jo und was ich mache ist
ich hab nen World ETF
da kommt jeden Monat
Kohle rein
und für kurzfristiges Geld hab ich
also wo man mal
wo man dran kommen muss schnell
oder wo man halt auch sagt hey da will man mal
mit einem ETF kommst du ja auch schnell dran
aber will man ja vielleicht nicht unbedingt
dann
da rausziehen
dann hab ich noch
Euro Overnight Rate Swap
gibt aktuell
3,9% im Jahr
es orientiert sich am Leitzins
von der EZB muss mal gucken wenn der wieder
runter geht
das ist quasi so was wie Tagesgeld im Endeffekt
nur das man sich keine
Gedanken drüber machen muss irgendwie über
über
Sicherungen bei ner einzelnen Bank das man nicht zu viel Geld
hat und sonst was
das hab ich falls ich mal dringend
irgendwie bisschen Kohle brauche weil irgendwie
was Notfallmäßiges ist
3,9 ist schon alt
naja wenn ich hier auf ein Jahr gehe
sagt Scalable wir sind bei 3,9
das ist natürlich jetzt rückwirkend für ein Jahr
das wird wahrscheinlich wenn es jetzt nur noch
3,5 sind
bisschen runter gehen noch
aber aktuell
sagt das noch 3,93%
dieses Jahr
ich bin nicht bei Nvidia nein
leider nicht
aber jetzt kauf ich auch kein Nvidia mehr
hätte ich mal machen sollen
aber nachher ist man immer schlauer
warum hab ich Millionen Tabs offen
weil ich meinen RAM irgendwie rechtfertigen muss
weil ich 64 GB RAM in dem Rechner hab
weil ich weiß was ich damit machen soll
es gibt Leute die haben
was weiß ich 200.000 Euro
in Tagesgeld oder so und das alles bei
einer Bank ist vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll
ja im Durchschnitt
hat der
im Durchschnitt
hat der 6,3%
das stimmt übrigens auch nicht genau
dass es 100k
dass es max 100k pro Bank Einlagensicherung
sind es sind maximal
100.000 pro
ich weiß nicht wie sich das genau nennt
so so Gruppe
ist das
also es ist ne Gruppe da sind mehrere Banken im Zweifelsfall drinne
und wenn du Pech hast
sind deine zwei Banken
in der gleichen Gruppe
es ist nicht wirklich pro Bank
die Einlagensicherung
es ist pro frag mich nicht wie das heißt
pro irgendwie
es ist irgendwie so ne Gruppe
da sind mehrere Banken drinne
ja gerade in DVG
ist ja auch bekannt
dafür niemals Leute zu bescheißen
Ne
Aktien sind davon nicht betroffen
weil dir die Aktien ja gehören
also langfristig
langfristig
kann man mit einem World ETF
gar nicht viel falsch machen
das Ding ist aber natürlich
ist das sagen wir mal so
das ist das Risiko
ärmste
von den risikoreichen Sachen
was du machen kannst
also solange die Weltwirtschaft
steigt über die nächsten Jahrzehnte
ist gut
wenn du ein World ETF hast
sollte sie das nicht machen
ist schlecht
also sollte sie das ab einem gewissen Punkt
gar nicht mehr machen
das du mal immer wieder so ein paar Krisen hast
dann geht es runter und wieder hoch
wichtig ist das man das langfristig sieht
über keine Ahnung 20, 25 Jahre
und
da ist das bisher noch nie runter gegangen
was natürlich
nichts heißt für die Zukunft
also wenn es jetzt
der dritte Weltkrieg kommt
und er zieht sich 20 Jahre hin
und die Weltwirtschaft ist im Arsch
hast du gelitten
ja
gab es gute Prime Deals
naja
ein Duschkopf
Amazon Handtücher
ein Jelly Button
ein Soundsystem
was ich mir nicht kaufen will
und Klingen für einen Rasierer
es hält sich doch sehr in Grenzen
was wir geiles gefunden haben bei Prime
dann haben wir andere Probleme als ETFs
ja dann kann ich
also wenn mein ETF abkackt
kann ich meine Krankenversicherung im Alter nicht mehr bezahlen
ich ärgere mich ja immer noch ein bisschen
manch einer mag das jetzt verwerflich finden
aber ich habe mir gedacht
als das in der Ukraine losging
habe ich mir eigentlich gedacht
ich muss Rheinmetall kaufen
ich habe schon lange einen
und wenn man sich einfach mal schnell morgens rasieren muss
das ist das beste was ich bisher hatte
auch wenn ich normalerweise
lieber Rasierhobel
heute habe ich wieder ordentlich rasiert
mit mit mit Seife und Hobel
aber für
man muss mal schnell oder muss man einfach schnell
irgendwie mal irgendwas weg machen
finde ich die One Plate Dinger super
ich find den Shit
also ich benutze den nur fürs Rasieren
für sonst nix
keine Ahnung wie die anderen Aufsätze so sind
so könnte der Friseur verwenden
den One Blade
der Frasier höchstpersönlich
Ideals stimmt guck mal mal was die immer machen
ich empfehle zum Obst schreien
da ist er wahrscheinlich wirklich Shit
du rasierst dann deine
Orange oder
ist der Hobel
nicht sehr schnittgefährdet
also ein Rasierhobel ist noch
das ungefährlichste was du machen kannst
da musst du
also da musst du dich schon
da musst du dich schon echt anstellen
dass du dich da schneidest
also das einzige was dir passieren kann
ist wenn du halt nicht richtig aufpasst
dass du dich quasi
wenn du zu fest drückst
oder zu oft über die gleiche Stelle drüber gehst
oder sowas
dass du dich dann
schneidest
oder wenn du einen falschen Winkel hast die ganze Zeit
ja da musst du ein bisschen aufpassen
aber schneiden so in Form von
wirklich Schnitte so mit dem Hobel
das ist schwierig die guckt ja auch
die Klinge guckt ja auch noch ein ganz kleines bisschen
raus also wenn es nicht gerade
dir schräg über die Backe ziehst
und selbst da weil so wenig raus guckt
wird nicht so viel passieren
bist du mit einem Hobel eigentlich relativ sicher
ja und trocken darfst du das Zeug
halt schon mal gar nicht benutzen
du musst immer vorher Seife benutzen
oder ähm
oder Creme
also Rasiercreme
oder Seife
Schaum aus der Dose finde ich btw
nicht so geil
das macht das Zeug nicht richtig nass
und nicht richtig geschmeidig
das ist einfach nur eklig
es hat so komische Stoffe drin
dadurch das es aus der Dose kommt
also ich mag ganz
oldschool so eine Seife
zum anrühren
das ist simpel
das schmeißt man in eine Schale rein
macht ein bisschen Wasser drauf
und dann nimmt man einen Pinsel
und rührt da drin ein bisschen rum
für eine halbe Minute
und dann hat man da so eine Seife
Wassermischung drin
und damit pinselst du dir den Bart ein
Watz ne Minute
dass das alles schön durchzieht
dann pinselst du vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen nach
und dann legst du los
und dann geht das auch ziemlich gut durch
mit dem Hobel
Leon Dankeschön für den Zap
und dann geht das auch ganz gut
zwischendurch muss man immer nochmal ein bisschen nach
nach äh pinseln
es gibt da zig Varianten
wie man es machen kann
wenn man sich die Videos im Internet anguckt
dann kriegst du erstmal warme Handtücher draufgelegt
und alles
also ich mach das meistens so
ich geh duschen dann ist das Zeug eh alles schon mal schön durchgeweicht
und die Haut ist auch schön warm
und alles
danach rühr ich mir die Seife an
pinsel das ein
während das ein bisschen einzieht
und einwirkt
die äh quasi
Rasierseife
pack ich den Rasierer aus
leg das alles immer hin
mach das Wasser an
und dann fang ich an mit dem Rasierhobel zu hobeln
wenn ich fertig bin
dann guck ich ob ich mich irgendwo geschnitten hab
ähm also
es ist selten das gar nichts ist
also wirklich schneiden tu ich mich eigentlich
jetzt mit ein bisschen Übung selten
aber man hat immer mal ein bisschen
irgendwo so einen ganz kleinen Kratzer
aber die bluten auch nicht großartig
man sieht einfach nur das es ein bisschen rot ist
also das gar nichts
das Null immer ist
das ist natürlich schwierig aber
man muss sich ja nicht gleich schneiden
also ein bisschen rot ist manchmal
sag mal das ist kein Ding ja
ich hab für solche Stellen hab ich so einen komischen Stein
kann man unter das Wasser halten
und dann drüber gehen
wenn es blutet dann stoppt das das
aber das ist meistens gar nicht notwendig
ähm
ja danach wasch ich das ab
und mach noch mal kaltes Wasser drüber
so und dann schmier ich
mir so ein Rasierbalsam drauf
so ne Creme
dass das alles noch beruhigt
ja ganz ehrlich war bei mir ähnlich
ich rasier mich auch erst seit
vielleicht
weiß ich nicht gar nicht so lange
drei Jahren oder so
hab ich früher nie gemacht
hab das früher immer mit elektrischen
Rasierern gemacht
bis ich mir eines Tages gedacht hab
warum ärgerst du dich mit diesem ganzen Shit noch rum
probier das doch mal
und da war ich richtig begeistert
von ich hab mir erst so einen komischen
Systemrasierer gekauft mit was weiß ich
180 plus 1 Klingen
da der Schwachsinn benutze ich gar nicht mehr
irgendwann bin ich auf ganz
klassisch Seife und Rasierhobel
umgestiegen funktioniert
am besten man schneidet sich
eigentlich nicht außer man
passt grob nicht
auf
und es ist angenehm
was für ein Stein ähm ja Moment
Rasieren Stein
sowas hier
wenn man sich irgendwo geschnitten hat
oder wenn es irgendwo ein bisschen rot ist kann man das drauf machen
das stoppt
das stoppt die Blutung falls es blutet
ich kann euch nicht sagen was ich für ein Rasierhobel
habe irgendein von Amazon
irgendwas von
von
Moment
aber das ist
ich will nicht sagen das es da keine Unterschiede
gibt aber
ich glaube das ist
jetzt nicht so essentiell
finde ich gar nicht
das Ding habe ich
das Ding
da kann man nicht wirklich was
falsch machen
du rasierst dich mit einer Holzfälle
richtig Alpha Male Style
das ist wirklich simpel
also du hast hier unten
du hast hier unten am Griff
so ein Ding das kannst du drehen
wenn du das drehst geht die Schraube hier raus
ja
dann legst du deine Rasierklinge so drauf
wie du es hier siehst
und schraubst es wieder zusammen
das dauert 30 Sekunden
und dadurch das deine Rasierklinge
wirklich nur so ein ganz kleines Stück hier raus guckt
neben
du hast ja wirklich nur so ein bisschen hier über den Rand raus
weil wenn du es drauf anlegst kannst du dich schon schneiden
aber es passiert eigentlich nichts
also ich kann es nur empfehlen
ich habe auch lange Zeit mich mit elektrischen
Rasierern rumgeärgert und
wollte mich nicht so richtig
ranwagen ans
nasse rasieren
ne ganz ehrlich das mit dem Hobelfunst gut Rasiermesser
das ist mir dann tatsächlich da muss man dann auch wieder
viel zu sehr aufpassen
da bin ich nicht so der Kenner
auch wenn ich in letzter Zeit öfters mal welche geguckt habe
aber bei mir hauptsächlich daran
dass mir die ganzen Streamingdienste auf den Sack gegangen sind
und Animes gucken ja so
wenn man so eine Grauzone ist
wie gut man da dran kommt
ich wollte noch mal kurz bei MyDeals gucken
ob die doch irgendwie was für Prime
empfehlen
Trending
was trendet denn
ok SSDs
äh Kaffeemaschine
ne ne wir gucken mal
wir gucken mal lieber
was lieber Prime Deals empfehlen
ok One Plate
Schwachsinn ey was juckt mich das
kann man das denn hier irgendwie sortieren nach Technik
oder so Filter
ne oder
ah doch hier oben
Keckel
Moin Nico
kann man auch sagen dass man das auf
ah Amazon kann man sagen
ist da irgendwas dabei
die zeigen einfach jetzt so 4000
irgendwas an das will ich ja gar nicht
ah hier wird gevotet
Fischer Dübel
brauche ich jetzt nicht
Moment
Baseballschläger mit
Stacheldraht ok das ist
das ist für äh Zombie
Roleplayer ok
Flexispot für die habe ich mal Werbung gemacht
auf Youtube
ok also
bleibt tatsächlich echt nur
der Duschkopf das Mikrofasertuch
der Shelly Button und ein paar neue
Rasierklingen für den One Plate
was nichts mit dem zu tun hat
was ich eben erzählt habe btw
elektrischer
minus 18% Baseball
das klingt auch ein bisschen falsch ne
ah kurz mal einen Tee trinken
hey Leute
wisst ihr
was jetzt ist
ich geh jetzt pennen
wollen wir mal wieder Outromusik probieren Leute
hatten wir schon lange nicht mehr
muss mal kurz gucken ob ich das finde
jawoll Outromusik
exzellent
Badkid Time
schön dass ihr am Start wart
wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream
und ich gehe mal davon aus
ihr geht wahrscheinlich gehen die meisten jetzt auch pennen
so in dem Dreh
Youtube Video bald
ich kann nichts versprechen
ich nehme es immer wieder vor und mache es dann nicht
aber ja ich denke schon
Sammy
ich kann mit Sammy kein Video machen
Sammy ist nicht meine Katz
ich könnte Sammy mal besuchen ja
also Leute
bis denn
tschüss